[音楽]
me
うづん
[音楽]
う
ぜん
[音楽]
安心山でやってるわけなんですけどこれ
なー
夏たい動画を出すというスター性
これからもメックス住んでるやっていこう
と思うチャンネルねーよ
始め x カンパニーにしました皆様の時
で
蔵六妻がいい
午前に行きましたありがとうございます
これ音に行きますよとうとうを超えたね
超えましたね僕が新しい名前はですね肇
社長ですお気づきの方もおられますと思い
ますがチャンネル登録者な5万人と
パターン車
ただいま5月7日の18時20分でござい
ますうわぁ
ジャンルのカッター
無事チャンネル登録者が100万に行き
ました本当にありがとうございますそれ
からもゆるーくいきますよ
自分のしたいことを追求して来て矢部から
も変化とかいろいろあるかもしれないです
けど
これだろ
よろしくうチャンネル登録者元いた場所
始め室をチャンネルチャンネル登録車ロン
名が万人超えましたーーー
ファイト雪で始まりは写真チャンネルで
ございますを燃やしがあまりと目立ってる
野菜畑という意味も込めてあはじめ者との
畑という中でプリキュア惰性で外れ冊を山
ネルちゃん冷蔵ん
900円
[音楽]
[拍手]
11月の25日にようやく
チャンネル登録者数が970万人を突破し
ました
ありがとうございます youtube を
始めて9年10年目えーなんですけれども
あと
30万人まず3000万人でチャンネル
登録者数が僕の長年の目標である
1000万人に相続するわけなんです
けれども本当に心の底から今の想いを
皆さんにお伝えするのであればとっても
1000万人に異字体ですもう本当に行き
たい深げさせてください編内に
1000万人
いきたいです
[音楽]
b 1 f
え坊
こんにちははじめ社長です名前シンナー
遊びの見てますかー
こんにちは
そして今日はですね mc で大地くんも
一人益田市農業よろしくお願いします
最初あれはなんだったんだ
はっ
はー
もう立って9年前とこれ
黒かった所いやもう
何がいればお金が足りてない悪いござい
ますかん
はいというわけで貯蓄第19回裏で mse
というかいろいろお話をしながら
れ始め社長のチャンネル登録者数がですね
今ちょっとコメントオーラーも一緒に見
ましょうかどんな感じになってるんですよ
こちらはい
は今997まあん
ああああ
ぬうっといっなにーくまてぃしたいと思い
ますぜひあさあ watch か東 to
do 父さんと母さんっっまず1つは見て
みてと言ってくれるととても嬉しいです
よろしくお願いします
まあお願いしますコメントみお
こんにちはこんにちはこんにちは
仕事中だけど見届けに来たぞありがとう
ございます
まっくすぼ茶をたくさんありがとうござい
ますえっそれ大丈夫もう
春万人
んですよすごいよね本当に長かったよ俺の
mc は本当に
もっと付き合いが長い大地くんかなと思っ
ているするとエッ
お願いしますけどありがたいどうぞ
よろしくお願いしますありがとうござい
ますお願いします
ん
山頂サーフ
俺こっちで5みんなみんなのコメント読ん
でるんでありがとうございます
水瀬以前万人ありがとうございます
正月補償額の線が智弁 b 全部流れてみ
まん
ってコアの音がクリスマスっていう感じで
はいっ
頑張りますありがとうございます今回バカ
じゃあのー
僕も頑張るんですけど
ぜひ皆3ネル登録が
力になるのでぜひお願いしたいです
[音楽]
それかもう23だね図2月
3日大竹はやっぱりお嫁さんとスロー
んない予定
ですねねえええ
いいなどこですかここは今ですねー
お祝いのためにちょっと特殊なスタジオと
言いたいんですけどもやううーむ株式会社
で撮影しております
この表文を張ったをしたら売られ
google になってるんだよ
特にほんと見た目正月ですごいんだよね
クリスマス直前だからなぁ
みんなどうしてクリスマスどういう予定
ですか皆さん
どこですか気になるよねえっ
千歌音ダンスポップスポーツありがとう
ございます1000万円のピンまでもう
少し頑張ってにありがとうございます
ありがとうございます
原末のご予定
年末はちょっとオリコ前的に申すとの月
落ちたくて寝ましょうじゃあもうね
しっかりと多分年末ものもハリセンしよう
と思っているうそー月期も早すぎでははい
もう
これの今年1年はこれに尽きると思ってる
んでん
ちょっと僕はも1000万人が今年の目標
なので
僕はお正月でしまった気持ちは正月でも
終わってますけどせねそれが続いた今年の
締めはもうこれにしたいなと思っており
ます
フォローしようとしたらしてたありがとう
ございます
お役に続けそうなんですよあ
そういうこれ今回ですねちょっと
気付いらみんなちょっと席が広いでしょ
一人にしては
何か座れそうなんですけど
ユーチューバーみなさーん
あの
今まではじめ視察をと仲良かったなーとか
思う人は
遊びに来てねー
切ってくれるからこれでいい
聞いて欲しいよね打っても水
ん
with ますも月につきましたジェット
で作りましたパーティーですと
いいなぁ
今までもう少し
そしてもうすぐ
998万人後
あと2万ちょい今にちょいだよっに入って
から剃りました応援してますありがとう
ございます
2尾シャツを9年やってるからさ
はいねそうやっぱり
なんか最近知ったという方もたまに
いらっしゃるんですよ
おっ
入館料ございますんを破きてくれるかな親
だい
love
お願いしますこれ l ジョンソ余分
見せます何するのあの明日でゆっくり座っ
て脚は車メンズジョーカーしたクリスマス
なんですけどもバッチリ朝から撮影で
ございます
それも結構
なんかこの生配信するっていうのもごめん
なさいなんか直前になって言っちゃって
あのいく瞬間をどうしても生配線したくて
ですね
珍しいよう頑張り生配信
それに対処しないもん
なんですけどどうしてもそのイク瞬間は皆
さんと見たくて
ちょっと難しかっ
すごい勢いだった時とか別日3万人とか
4万人チャンネル登録してくださった時も
あったんでなかなか
コック地するタイミングを難しかったん
ですよ
一日前に言ってさ
その非常に伊勢マニー pict か本当
にちょっと嫁なっててスピード感がする
までかなり尻切りということですごいなん
か twitter とかでへ by と
あるんですけどいつ
みたいなブルっ終わったんですけども知れ
ませんちょっとこればかりは言えなくて
そんなんがゲディオン的な感じになって
しまいましたすいません
友達に専念続きますありがとうございます
第一に彼を見たいって大丈夫か売りたい
エイプモントン
町内てるんですよ
はいアーサー合っちゃったらこうして a
ちょっといい絵こそ
茂ってない魅力を持っている
ユーチューバーのゲスト来る前に俺が反っ
ちゃうあの本当に入るとかもー
肇社長の山寝るにを切ってやっぱり大竹は
肇社長の働きが始まる前からほんと支えて
もらってたに
なんかめちゃくちゃ長いさあ
揚々とかやったじゃんやったね揚々だっけ
よ8日4よあと日焼け半分だけせるだけも
な
磯部つが裏で見あっ900ゲージ八幡に
行きました
ありバニー
あとなんだよ
いやっいいよね
[音楽]
本当にそうだから結構レイド中では本当に
はじめシャツを
ちゃん手によってきくんちにパーソンと
いうか本当に支えてもらった人で
5ドアねー2を止めてね社会に出たけど
だったらはじめがいいということである
ちょっと失礼してくれた彼らは
ほんとそれでないがより一層ねー
絆は固くなったというか
3県のうちもすごい
最新立つためにあのおとといガスでました
あ猫じゃね今年初めて三軒の家でお風呂
入れました
[音楽]
がとうございますけどもっと
宜しくお願いします
本当に
食べますおめでとうですよ
[音楽]
いうか
イブとさん
クリスマスってどっちがう
飯野その恋人という固有
の20
的に仲良くイヴっていうイブストーン翼が
たくさん来てる k さんありがとう
ございます
[音楽]
そのたくさんありがとうございます
和実くん頑張って下さい大好きですいつも
元気をくれてありがとう love
jump さんありがとうございます
元気をもらっているのは私の方です
本当にありがとうございます
中学生の頃から見てました
当日はあさって25巻
25もねあの
多分これどこかで生配信できてると思うん
だよその楽しみにしててください25も
26誰ですよねあの撮影ですよね
1000万に入ったからといって私は足を
止めません
動画でも言ったと思うんですけどもやめ
ないので1000万に行っても
より肩の力抜いて頑張ら頑張ろうと思っ
てるねー
全然これはこれからだと思っています始め
刺そうという
あと昨日の占い
みました突然裏になって
いただきっ
見てもいいですか
が全然違っちゃう前
占いの番組に出させていただいたんです
けれども僕来年の2月からなんか転機を
迎えて何かもっとすごくなれるって言われ
たんで
肇社長は1000万人では止まりません
ここではっきり言わせてもらいますここ
からです
けどあのやっぱり
100万人入ってからもう何年かならねー
年ぐらい経ってるねー
そうだ超
長年
[音楽]
何かそれの10倍って思うと本当に
なんか
[音楽]
あんなにブックそのチャンネル登録お願い
します何万に行きたいんです
この
今年までに行きたいですとか言わずに
テッククールに来たんですけど
ちょっとっ
最後は結構泥臭くというか
[音楽]
ていうんだろう
あんまり
結構かっこつけなんですけど
部分
をつけずに最期を1日パシってみようかな
と思って
1000万人行きたいって今年は今年だけ
図2月かな通知がさん12月11月は本と
言い続けました
2000万人目だと過ごす伊勢萬に行く
ぞーありがとうございます
[音楽]
のがスポーツあったらどの4ザっていいよ
わかりました僕はのスパツアーを始めて
いただきました
パター等ログスパつ開いてなくて
あの生配信で
初めてさっきスパツアーの設定しました
初めて4発もらっていますありがとう
ございますございますそうそれどうも
ありがとう
も今ありがとう
テレビみましたありがとうございます
[音楽]
袴くる j
ん
なんで袴でもやっぱなんかいっ
ピチッとした形の運勢マン
鍛造も使
エコついてるのなんでに凝っているあうっ
ているちょっと大丈夫
青木月
[音楽]
泣いていいですね山田泣いてないよ
うまくと思います俺
ないたことないけど人生デー
なくっ
肝臓なんだろう
甘い好きだよはいどうもありがとうござい
ます
[音楽]
腕がとー
やー
わー
皆さん今来た方もいらっしゃいましたら
是非よろしくお願いします始めシャツを
目指す1000万円でツイートしてくれる
と twitter みお
[音楽]
みんな良かったらぜひ拡散して下さいお
願いします
お願いします
[音楽]
まあトレンドにちゃんと載ってたすごい
てビッシュ解散するん
その
h の初いつ出てきているえっ
m ちゃんそれぞれはさんねっ
[音楽]
藍ネイルかな
ちゃんと言いま
イルカ見えません
[音楽]
のってマジここ日本とがすごい
これか
すいませんカメラ三千余年
行かれる
あ存在されません
4トレード乗っていますありがとうござい
ますみなさーん
[音楽]
びっしゅ解散するん
ちょっとやまりなよ水4日に田舎そばを
話せおらず足と所バイザー
変な世界的でほんとっ
一気に汗ぐん
こんばんは頑張ってありがとうございます
998万2430
乳頭03たで
ん
おっ
7年前くらいに初めて見たユーチューバー
が始めたんですね恐れどうもありがとう
ございます2000万に頑張りありがとう
ございます
そのなんかいろんな方によく言われるのが
始めシャツをでユーチューバーというもし
れましたっていうことはすごいて大
嬉しいなってなんか結構入口登竜門みたい
な桜
感じになってるらしいですありがとう
ございます本当に
まずありがとうな中年親父ていると
やっぱり
視聴者さんもさなんかずっと見てくれる人
もいらっしゃるし
あれ突然めっちゃリプ送ってきてくれると
ずにツイッターで聞いたな
ああいう後に戻ってきたっていう方も
いらっしゃいますし
ずーっと永井千佳応援してくださってる方
もいるんですけど
参加を覚えています皆さんありがとう
ございます
コメント読むか
[音楽]
歩くと連絡とか来てない大丈夫妙
誰かいなぜかん
あの大学の後輩からしくってねあっはぁ
職場から応援していますそうあの
広範囲もたくさんいたんだけどみんなは
もう
卒業してさ学生を
[音楽]
酒井砂ような
ないよねもの
逆にね来ている人も減ったかなって
水が流れを感じじゃねぇ
[音楽]
youtube japan さん
もっちりをしてくれてますありがとう
ございます
[音楽]
娘を読みにしてほしいまだ11歳だけど
応援してますまた良いんじゃないん
7年女性て16歳から結婚できるんですよ
18ズーク
[音楽]
あとでも11歳の方なんか8と7年近くは
ちょっと待たないといけですよ
僕で大丈夫ですか
[音楽]
ちょっと受験菊炭君のくだらない面白い
動画でなんと元気をもらったがずっと応援
していますありがとうございます
新潟なんかさぁ皆さん真面目にしゃべる
動画再生されるようにそれだよねすごい
この前の動画もこの前のやめますっていう
話の雲がもう結構再生
されているあって真面目な方がいいんです
か
ni逆にいつもふざけてる動画とってる
から
そういう俺が突然は爪の話するとやっぱり
めっちゃのかもしれないねなんだこいつ
ねえぞ腕を車乗りたいな
どこなんですかねちょっと1000万に
いったらー
方向とかも変えてみたくて
ちょっと色んな事にも挑戦してみたいと
思っております
なんかツイートしようって言っ何かあって
ん
[音楽]
想像シューティングブロ
ズンズン3階は250円スパートしてくれ
ましたありがとうございます寝たら全然ん
[音楽]
お登勢ももう終わりだ
何年かありがとうございます
[音楽]
正起こないかなってコメントきますね正木
ダメ皆さん覚えてますまず機
懐かしすぎる
鮮烈のおねーって言われてずっと
後6年前かなたくさん撮ってたのさあ年
くらいん
ね彼も私が戦慄のオネエという二つ名を
与えてからうんその名を馳せてい
活動を活躍していたんですけど
なーさすがに1000万人たら出てきたり
しないでしょ
何酒そろしいです
覚えているりがとー
彼もきっと喜んでいると思います
それ地をたどると本当にながいい
よな10年間
あれも保証月
違うんです皆さんさんネル登録よろしくお
願いします今喜多方
すごいどんどん視聴者数が増えていって
ますねtwitter でこちら外れ
シャツを水瀬1000万人でぜひツイート
していただけると嬉しいです
宜しくお願いします
生貝せ俺あんまりしないから何喋っ
親分どういう話せてだけ生はいすぐとして
まっ
8割くるって言ってか遊べ一応早すぎて
塗りたいことができなかったってを応援し
た時話してたら5分
を屋バー
を押すと分
と過ごせてありがとうございます
6年ぐらい応援してますずっと大好きです
程度には気をつけてねあとっていう裏が
突然ですが占っていいですか見ました
ありがとうございます
さっき懐かしいねぇ
ね
始めたハル君畑からスマ者がまじでん
今皆静岡にんじゃないのみんな静岡に言う
と思う
床
笹間さん1000万人はありがとうござい
ます
そういうまでがんだよ
編者なくわけねーでしょ俺がう
見たことあるが泣いたところ
ありがとうございます2000万人まで
あと少し頑張ってくださいアスパラガス
ありがとうございます
初めて出会ったのはメントスコーラでした
これからも頑張ってください
通学生から見続けて今は大学生です
ますありがとうございます
かも
頭大の流れを感じる9年間経ってるという
言葉に映る初めて
11歳だった人が羽立になっているって
所得てですよ
飯高くださいありがとうございます
本当にありがとう
何かやってほしい
何かあってほしいまま待ってくださって
咲かせん
伊勢マンに入ったらまたシナモンさんにし
てください
わかりましたーー
ちょっと待っててめっちゃ人にちゃった
護衛した後チャレンジとぅなんで危険ん
じゃなかったっけいうかいっ
そうだねなんかのと詰まるからみたいな
[音楽]
畑スポーツありがとう
すごいトレンド1位なんだね inred
1位だってこのトレンド1
待ってこういうの見るとちょっとウルッと
きちゃうなぁ
[音楽]
皆さん今日本のトレンドはじめ雪を目指せ
1000万についです
ありがとうございまーす本当にありがとう
ございます
てくれよ
はツイートしよう
お腹に生配信中にちょっと twitter
いじるでっ
トレンド1
すごいにトレンド1
伊達がくれてうまく打てない
すごいもうスパーチャーがすごい
はじめに1000万人までもう少しが
頑張ってねつまらん
マダマダマ
ずっと大好きです応援してますありがとう
ございます
本当にありがとう
やっぱりもう少しっていう動作もう即死
って言うとずと全然違うけると
本当に入った
見ていっ
からかー
その時から見てる人ももう
打つだろうなんか
youtube の好きなことで生きて
いく cm とかも何年前だろ5年前とか
なん
その他に13の時とそうだねー
高校生はもう
5年経ってるかな
社会人だねない掛けおねむ性とか
が成長してるんだろうな
向かせ水だ人も
はじめのスポーツしてくれた方でござい
ましたありがとうございます
本郷くんを見てます本当に
母感触
を気がせえよねはーいあっ
学ぶ体験いますようんまたが者や作家
北海道から声
あっ
どう使ったと思います
成果で工藤さん
ちょっと果じゃあお前が
が図面中学校の頃からずっと見てました
銀座21歳になり今でもはじめの動画を見
てます頑張りありがとうございます
ありがとう
相次ぎはどうですかはず3冊をの
チャンネルと
ナイツ3つから一緒に仕事をするだっけ
年前くらいだねなんか
この思い出がやばかった見てなります今
まで10個の思い出
これがよくも悪くもないですよ良くも悪く
もに
会でもう結構しんどかったのは一緒にいつ
だってでさっき話にあった日焼けの100
日焼けねー
なんだけど体判断マジックで黒塗り指定
黒って
太陽を聴ける吸収するか開けしない説と
いうので
反応でちょっと買って語ってたんですよ
世代第二くんが危ないから席だって開けて
熱中症とかあるかと付き添いで見てくれた
んですね大竹の熱中症なんです俺がなっ
ちゃったってて
フィドラ bot の3大課題作ってたら
来てくれた俺ああああ
いろんなことしたねほんとにほんとに
篤人
さん呼びますねコメント
thrive かぶりませんか
スライム動画ねー
あの掃除機と昨日撮ったんですよ
とったちょっとねかなり世凱に撮ったん
ですけど
このタイミングでいい
このタイミングが生配信かなと思って
さっきも惹かれさんとのコラボ動画出させ
ていただいたんですけどちょっと米セレブ
度を出す前にもいい
いきたいですスライム同柄の
近いずに出しますねに
せ倍もかかりませんかっていうなんか何か
見たんじゃない
グーグーの仲人の時から始めたその動画を
見てますこれからも応援してます大好き
ですありがとうございます
今1000万におめでとうございますてい
た山田じゃないかちょっと待てません
先走ってるなぁ
海外ファンファンも応援してます
ありがとうございます
海外からもありがたいなぁ
はじめにずっと大好き応援してるよー伊勢
万人ウケきーちゃんありがとうございます
なめらかプリンさん何だかんだで7発年前
から頭痛動画見させていただきましたこれ
からもをすると思っていますありがとう
ございます
本当にありがたい
ちょっとずつパ
押さなきゃ1000万人入ってからくるか
もしれないから大岩井的な感じで
それまでは一人で頑張るいてなんかもしれ
ない
どうなんですかね
裏でマネージャーさんが下を向いていまし
たイェイ
work
ちょっと待って待ってるんですね色んな人
がはじめしたと1000万人でついさせて
twitter 見ると
感動する
これって何かぴ bgm てきた作ったり
しません
何流れてるんだろっ
今すぐ見たりましょう夫たちがわかり今
すぐに食べましょう
組あるん
一家全員はじめ大好きです笑笑笑中学生の
今専門学生になった
[音楽]
ホント皆
始め視察
っていう名前だけ知っている人がいるよう
です軽い
大人の方とか結構いらっしゃってい
弾み札を手をずさんなのお姉ちゃんと冊
あって作っていたがちょっと年ペルミなん
だね
けど実際動画見てみたらまた来てびっくり
したっていうあの
娘さんと息子さんのあの
親の保護者の方からたまに来る
こっちは鍵屋みたいっ
けどこれも28歳ですよもう
太陽も28でないよもう
到達見届けられると
頑張っても頑張ります
この9年で3人の母になりましたん
big ことを言い俺つはもう俺もここ9
年で3つのチャンネルの主になりました
どうなるんだろうこの先の前世
角度が出ているという
ちょうどご存知ですか
頑張りありがとう
そしています2冊7万7千人です
ありがとうございますありがとうござい
ます
今今見てくださっている方いらっしゃい
ましたらあ2
今観てくださる方
今見た方いらっしゃいましたらこちら
ハッシュタグ始めたつを目指せ1000万
人でぜひツイートやお友達やあっ家族や
恋人を家にいるペットなどに通してあげて
ください
おっ
大丈夫何かおもしろいことを言ってあぁ
もう緊張し過ぎてウケる吐きそうだった
わけね別らしく渋くそう静かになっちゃっ
て
そうはするけど
笑顔でいきたいところではあります
初発ですあー
行くぞねそれおやつねー
蓮の葉カストやばかったね
なんか
あんまり自分で唯一自慢があっても感です
他のユーチューバーさんとかクリエイター
さんわかんないですけど
やらせしないじゃんと切り花一切しない
けどねエグゾディアホントにマジでやって
て
あの肇社長の動画の金賞とか
ドッキリと基本やらせないんで基本でいい
からやらせないんであの
反省してみてください
逆に失敗してはそれでやっちゃうからんて
たってっていうのはちょっと諸刃の剣です
けどもずっと目指せだけはしたくないって
いう
はなさんの1億円のつかみ取りの千景さん
に5000枚持ってかれたのも本当に
ちゃんと
5000万円なんだよ
あーそしてチャンネル登録者数が
998万円9,000円
メッツの人500行きました動い
アド一番500人かな
本当にありがとうございます
それを何度ズームしとけばよかったなぁ
なんか何番に行ったら何します見たいのは
確かにね
業務市和見したかったこちらの猟具と福祉
課詰めしなかったやっ
なんですけどあの皆さんチャン島
誰かクリエイターさんがお祝いに来て
くれるかもしれないです
まあ
銀蔵ズレ
100人よく参加させていただきました
ファイトでされございます作品のぴあで
ございます
職人よっきーさん
スタジオはで24時間で作曲されてたの
24時間抑えて低
ワンちゃんも
24時間やるつもりではありましたファー
999万人デー
ガード5万人でもう
俺がすごいきっちょしして
一番に言ってよいつもに入ったねうわぁ
[音楽]
まずちょっと待って米喋れなかったで
ござるだけどヘアー
大勢が余っちゃう web の本で作り
ますよね
皆さん本当にありがとうございますあと
一番人気りました
あと少し音質ますずっと見てるよ
ありがとうございます
あの
[音楽]
1000万人までほんと youtube
いろんな中でがあってさー
最近のゆずブドウが長い山長い
長い it さあ30分とは40分とかっ
て立ってるの動画みん
すごいと思ってい
かその子改変指数のすごいと思うんだけど
なんか昔プレートに光からするとさあ
見ている方のスキマ時間になったらいいな
と思って嘘のようだな
移動ついとか
q 値1とか2した時間
クスッと笑ってもらえたらもう何嬉しいか
なと思っていたんだけど
うん彼に最近道路がすごい長くなってきて
いる
ん
youtube のそういうも変わってき
てるんだなと思ってたんですけど最近逆に
さをショートっていうサ短い動画を知って
まで山の館で短い線
俺結構は自分向いてるのかなと被ってあぁ
んあぁ見てるけど姉ちゃんヌー
めちゃめちゃ覚えたらはからなんか面白く
なってくださいかあっ
あのほらうちのおうじコンビに作った
じゃんはい
あでも母ちゃんすると拠点は400万再生
いって言って存在店の数よっ
母ちゃんが言えない歩いただけ
えっ
風に流れで400万歳する
いつ見ていただけて本当に感動感動とか
凄いなって思って
ひょっとしたら
イヤホンが絡まってるらしいね受け果たし
ます
語った業務的だねえっ
ありがとうございますみなさん本当に
トイレとバス停前だったこれ俺の
頑張って下さい末行ってあげたんで
ありがとう協力してくれて
ごはん作りながら見てます頑張れ
ありがとう
名誉ぱれているとってもこもこモコレット
は難しいトイレの
を持つが覚めたわ俺
この子もコレットで言えるトイレの玩具あ
そねた男が今や言えぬの中で遊園地作って
ますからなんですね
あーなんか
いろんなことをやってきてい
この時が良かったと彼の時が良かったッ今
が良かったと思う言われるけどいろんな
時代を
youtube やってきたんですけど
ぞの時代が良かったから俺もよくわかん
ない4
本当に常に楽しいんで
本当に動画を見てくださっている方が
いらっしゃる
is は僕はも
自身は自信を持ってというか本当
自分が楽しいと思っていることを動画にし
ていきたいと思っています
バケツなバケツにハマって抜けなきゃって
はじめように見えましたよ始めました
内掛けません
そういうことをやってたに俺
本当にできなくて
つらかった本当に綺麗だと思うんだよね
ちょっと切れなかった
びっくりサポ自分でも
動画だってもう2500本近く出すする
から1500
今からさはじめ冊を知った人にさー
なんか軽い気持ちで全部見てください
なんて言えなくている
目がまとめたよねそういうそうだねうん
動画見とけばた爪シャツがわかり女ん
の中には重い謝罪どうかと思いますけれど
も
そういうのまとめてみたい日課一音だねぇ
あと4後6000人切りました
はずまたでっ
ズボンコーナーねー
いこーなー
さっき質問下げすぎてくれ答える俺のあの
引き出しがなくなっちゃいますね
いただけます
ちょっとまたやろっかな1000万人記念
とかでも
いう形を模したねー
中学も知ってたまま
入学2さーん
その学校行くで忙し的でどうぞ取れなくて
書庫の紹介動画1週間れておりますという
じゃっん
でもなんか何かにはそういうのが好きって
言ってくれる方もいますがそれは確かに
ネイルたんですよ
技法が江一派下がっ
静岡たら応援してますありがとうござい
ます
17人今
主張されているありがとうございまーす
ありがとうございますずうマンネ組のもう
少しです作ろうかしてくださいよろしくお
願いします
あ今これいらっしゃった方はこちらはじめ
冊をみなさん1000万人でぜひツイート
宜しくお願いします
あともう少しです
大好きありがとうございます
ずっとプラネタリウム熱くフエラムネの
企画に
付選べるでねんかん演奏会向けられたこと
があってい
しかしにうまい棒のイベントに行きました
ありがとうありがとうございます
まーと
ちょっとはって本当に
お待たせライブをやってほしい
ちょっと明日以降も本当に多分年内
しばらく
結構ぶっ飛んだ道が出ると思うんですよ
1000万人いくまで年ないよもう全力で
いこうと思ってて
キックを
しばらく
んですっ
a 4がみたいなのが出るかもしれない
です
5都市対抗6
たくさんどうだったということ思ってるん
だよねー
あの1000万に入ったからっていう本と
いったんですけどやめるわけではないし
やめる気はないんで皆さん10日暗線して
これからも肇社長についてきてください
も将来どうなっちゃうんがいつくん
止まっちゃうんだろう
5000人切りましたねー
本当
高いもうすぐだ
はいけない議論そう
[笑い]
ほんのというの1位だよありがとうござい
ます今ツイッターはじめしゃちょー目指せ
シューマン日本の酉の市らしいです
ありがとう
[音楽]
ポケモンのルナと思う好きですかあんまり
好きじゃないかも7
それロッテの方が好きです
どういう思想性のスパで質問コーナー3で
写ってるけど
まりまあ今リーマンから
する小物
これほんまですかね
今で多分
これでおいしい焼肉の見ちゃって下さい
応援してます by デイジーで500円
いきます
練習ありがとう
健康
真の礼二くん
黒 p たが医師免許取得できたのお勉強
動画のおかげだよありがとう前か受験中に
さあ始め社長の何かその事件の動画見て
すごいやる気掛けたというコメントが
たくさん
今もくる
強引
中野
これ生放送見てるから受験生いらっしゃっ
たら
[音楽]
ほんと勉強辛いと思うんですけども
6でやってください6であんな考えれば
考えるほど勉強する意味を飛びとっ
取り出したりなんで勉強しなきゃいけない
んですけど考えれば考えるほどやる気
無くなるんで
頭巾勉強は本当にやるだけですひたすら手
を動かして
勉強するという
文頭の戦いだと思うので
ぜひ受験生の方これも染みてくださって
たら頑張って下さい受験勉強
[音楽]
なんかちょっと待って
すごい
松垣記事でちょっと全部よりあげたいなぁ
早くも12万22万人等手続2万人です
ありがとうございますけどねまーすん
埋めてコメントします
流れてしまいます
手前考え歌ってくださいませんえっ
ちょっとあれはレッスン僕一人だけじゃ
なくてですねもう一人北あい方が
いらっしゃいまして
出前館のうタワーが相方がいないでござい
ません
[音楽]
どんな気持ちですか
今ねー
[音楽]
うれしい
純正にもう一そうだって嬉しいドキドキと
なんかこの9年間の
初泳ぎ下げてくださいフェスだとコメダレ
スって反応するんだよね売れないちょっと
か言いたいこと言いますねんか9年間の
思い出
辛いことが楽しいこととかいろいろあった
んですけどそれが年間いろいろよみがえっ
てきてちょっと懐かしいなとか
なんか
感慨深いというかウルっときてる気もつも
あります
リスです本当に
まず3万人
してもらっているのかありがとうござい
ます
どこのたくさんの人に観ていただいて
1000万人を迎え入れることがすごい僕
が幸せだと思ってて
本当にまず
皆さんに感謝しています見てくださって
いる
たまにでも見てくださってるかターン
実写っていらっしゃると思うんですけど
もう本当に動画を見てくださって全員に
感謝してます
流れて音が今ユーチューバーれるとが流れ
てるねこれ多分そう
音もいいなぁ
ずっと見てるありがとう
と人生初4発は貰ったのでどこを見れば
わかりません
同じくんだっていうえっ
あと1500人切りましたーーー
歯が痛いですスパでいうこと
歯が痛いですスパっていうことされ
1000万円から全国イベントしちゃう
全国行き大変
ちょっと
行きたいねちょっと頃なぁ
ちょっと今
を知っ築地つもあるけどまたちょっとね人
が増えてきてるから気をつけながらまた
できる機会があれば全国行きたいですね
あいぜん背に浸し煮付けにしたいっ
[音楽]
同じ目線に来た
the voice 事すごい早くすごい
少しそうやって待って待って待って待って
待っていっ
あと802も切っている
みんなで留めますどうちょいなぁ
ありがとうございますもう少しもう少し
まだ早すぎ in 最後
動くまあすごいすごいすごい
も次いだ
とうとうチャンネル登録させてもらいまし
たトート
おっおおっ
今までします
で300人持って訪れるあま決まっていれ
ばやばいやばいまで張らができません
ああっ行きました
が出来ましたーーー
[音楽]
すごい打って最後早すぎて
とった
バーンあったね
反応で人買ったなぁや雛てありがとう
ございますありがとうございますつづく
1000万に行きました
ありがとうございますありがとうござい
ます
ちょっと待って ed なりすぎて真面目
でもう2戦にも増えてるんだけどは止まっ
てこの後からのその感じ
頑張って戻っ
歩差まで詰まった30編を待ってみんな何
でそんなとねええええっ
で皆様
9999999人
年に1000万人になりたかったんかな
そういうことでもうすごい@5000
右打ちの違
ありがとうございます
bikke びっくりっ
本当にみなさんありがとうございます
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
浅く5位
てみるん
いう安心というか
そうだねー
どういう気持ちなんだろうなもん
でもチャンネル登録決定
その動画を見るとかじゃなくて弾み視察を
これからも見たいと思って教えてくれる
行為だから
それをねほんとに1000万円ぬ人がをし
てくださってるって言うのが
何でしょ
ですかね
です
が苦痛と今日なきゃでじゃなかったらなぁ
にありがとうございます
あの
ないた時に流してくださいって言っといた
bgm ですかね
用意してたくって
本当に良い方ありがとうございます
なんかチャンネル登録って自分がどんだけ
頑張っても
[音楽]
みんながあっ
したいって思わねとしてくれないことだ
から
俺は自分の力
ではなく
ボタンを押してくれたみんなの
おかげだと思ってます
僕以外にもユーチューバーすごい頑張っ
てる人って多くて
もちろんがって言ってる人もいるけど
頑張って動画作ってもさー
それが数字とかチャンネル登録に
見合ってない人ってすごい大キテるん
その中でもこれだけ多くの人にいい
評価されて
チャンネル登録しつってくださってる
のがすごい僕は幸せだと思っています
[音楽]
本当にありがとうございます
九州男 bgm がめっちゃ泣けるなぁ
朝ドラになりそうですね
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
このあとどうせますあ
a ちょっとあいっ
[音楽]
技で姉あ
ちょっとあの
[音楽]
ここから色々ず準備しているのでぜひ皆
さんまだはじめシャツを目指せ
1000万円まだ続くのでぜひ
時も見てください
うわぁ
ありがとうございます本当にっ
明日 a い
nor ん
だかんっ
上バッハ
ran
うわぁ
今年2人で行けてよかったようっ
[音楽]
一番泣いてるよんっ
受けるダウンとにいるぞよいやーやっぱ
持ってるよね
この年開けちゃうとちょっとなぁと思っ
たらちゃんと年代に振っていうことで
ございます
江戸ではねまだまだね我々
まだまだですよねそうですねサー
ちょっと
まだあるんでまだまだあるですか
ずっと待ってるんだよあれど
ハリアー当該今日レベルはもうこれずっと
とっちゃダメわかりますこれ
うわぁホラーめでたう野党ぜあっはい
いいえありがとうござい三重
通すが入って
あっはぁサッと塗っちゃうねさあそうなん
か1000万に入ったと思ったらすぐ一新
5000万円つだから間違ってわけで
1001万円1000万合成認証それまで
食べました
ずっとねえんだ
web いらっしゃったのも知ってたん
ですけど
うん見た瞬間がスゴイな
パーシー角度しかっ日お母さんみたいなっ
てるねすごい服も guys えっだから
少女めでたいから強度さあ昼に言うんだ
もーんでまぁ今日やるんですけどブルー
レイみたいななんかボスだけなくても
やっぱりにベロんだよねーユースいうのが
あるいは言え a
ありがとうございますのでいや後あともう
一個えっそんなにうん
そんなたくないん
とっておきの子だお
開けてくださいありがとうございます
マーケティングで全税
すっ
平和に入ったのをちょっと女だけども矢吹
と思うあっ
だって数本当にへ
なんか
親分
貼っ抜かれて米前マン日程
5呼ぶんだとめちゃくちゃ
にしても立派な前に見せてい
泣いてるのを見てくるんだって5位
ことっ
なんとか一番いい
いうことに行こうと思っていた
婦人靴を
[音楽]
ねちょっと箸でちょっとことだと思うね
いやいっすよねやっぱクレイジーですよね
そこが入ってるぜってやってやるって言う
もう何が3つを守って
頑張りました
わけでもいいまずジバニャンだよ失礼し
ます
これはこれはこうですかねっ入ってもいい
fendi まだアースプラスチックです
ね
俺なんか注意とかしてんのかなみたいな
いやいやいやらが iphone とかで
配信するのかなみたいな何もやってない
じゃんかそこでもいきなり屏風ではよかっ
たんだよね難しかったけど昨日テレビの
番組自体があって阿蘇の間に超えちゃうか
もよじゃあねもうなああそっかそっかそっ
か外でも案件道路側溝と舐めちゃべっても
良くないのかを作るちょっとコントロール
してるよねあっ
寄れなくてまぁねぇ
を貼っておきます o
順調入っ
何ですかいい
できます
[音楽]
結局別でこれはこれは
pb とクレイジーでこれで全部しちゃい
ます
すいませんだってっ
トレイこれぞれあのね今日の昼に
2012年もで一番いいやつを称えよう
探し回りで図面ものメックスちゃんねる
創設した年の
作った年の一番おいしいばいいので今度
一緒に動画撮りながら
んのみたいなどうもぜひお願いします
ありがとうござい八柱こそ
品化を目指す
ありがとうございます来年1100万人
どっちがいい3日うわぁは鍵1200万人
時また俺干されてるか受けないからね得る
まだ僕頑張りましょうまたよきライバル
です以下がローゼさあ
っていう本当にありがとうございます
あ
ないと
あっハウスくださいやつ
ありがとうございます音です
ん
声ベルぞ
安心感が凄いちょっとだった
ありがとうございます本当にん
winder ちょっとこれ大事にとって
おきたいなそうだねそうしたいっ
動かせないん
うそ
photo by が付いております
[音楽]
プラン水にはヤバかったり見てますなぁ
かこれならないん
[音楽]
まあそのちょっと俺
どうぞよろしくお願いします
ありがとうございますうわぁ凄い
こちらそれぞれは卓さんからで
google さんからですかねマジで
すかっ
チャンネルのヘッダーの
倒れてる肇社長だ
皆さん google さんからです
ありがとうございます
sm に登録おめでとうございますという
黄色大きいんですか
絹経ちらー
[音楽]
誰々ておりますあのゲームの方にすいませ
ん
ありがとうございます v
結構食べれるんです
いただきます
2時まで写真撮ろ
すぐ媚び
ありがとうございます
すごい退いて食べるんこれ
いこ
そのマックもまた多い状況だよ
それにしています
ただ行った
おっ
うーんまん
あんま
あとで食べます
ちょっとそこようにひとり食べきれないん
でいられません
俺釣られております
人とネットの情報ってこれ twitter
見ていい
[音楽]
まあね4 a でもこたつ玄門発を打って
くれてたみたい
ありがとうみんな
[音楽]
待っても一番に行っちゃうこれすごく
すごいねとにありがとうございます
ありがとうございます本当に
詰まっているんです
感じます
んですもうすぐまたすごい勢いだな
ございますもうみんなこの際チャンネル
登録お願いしまーす
はい占い師によると僕は来年の2月から
すごいらしいので
いうと1月はすごくないかもしれません
あっはっ
2月からちょっと頑張ります
めっちゃケーキっている
1銀座本当にありがとうございます
見てるこっちもすごいもう泣きそうになっ
ちゃった
ちょっとヒカキンさんはずっと思い入れが
終え願ってつかなくてね
ものみたいにあるだろう
ひょっと本当に
の方はねぇん
そういう人じゃないと思っている
[音楽]
ここにもちろん高め合いたいんですけど
確認さんは本当に
すごい
俺が叶わないちょっとっ
ok
プレゼントに盗んで
食べたいでしょだよねっ
year old the 角屋例えば
本当にいやああ
なんか
普通にあっちでめちゃめちゃ泣きました
咸宜をまっちゃったなぁフィズあるの視力
が来てくれますわー
とびがとーいやいやこちらこそ
めちゃめちゃだっていいタイミングとか
結構なんかその
辛いタイミングとかね家行かせてもらう
ことだったじゃないあそうだったんです
けど結構いろんなはじめ口を僕見てる
初めてちゃんと動画とか動いているえっと
あれですよねあの家でやったテンション
根強い
ティションのやつてフードシルクと
なかなか良くなったのがそうですねん
また雨がお家の月止まっていた時の際ね
家の奥路がなくて
ドラン肝心店シルフとグッドら幹部入ろう
ぜええ
一緒に風呂入ったらあれめちゃくちゃ
おもろかったけどね列車
懐かし
ソースなあのあともうなんか撮影なぁと
いろいろ話していっ
行ったりとか僕が多分
文章に入ってちょっとした後に一緒にた
シカゴファーにいたというハーイ時って
溜まりと
あの時に何か色々と教えてもらったって
いうんだけど
なんかすごいその方が1000万人言っ
たってこのタイミング等がいるって
めちゃくちゃ感動しありがとうございま
でー
本当に普段かな遊ばすとんだよねぇー
唯一ドラゴンセンター北小園ガッツリあっ
たりガッツリ遊んだりすっ youtube
の3+からしずく
あんなにクリエイターさんの遊びじゃない
んですそうそれだと端行く一番多いんじゃ
ないかなって本当にいいんだと思う
スマブラここにされたかっ
へどまたやりましょうやろうとお腹にまず
やりましょう店の強い何何ますねバッハ目
がたまたま里は4つたまたまポンポンに
買う人に聞くと左翼はスマグラーをゲーム
と思ってなくて格闘技だと思うあっはぁ
読み合いってフッ
確かでそれがあるかもしれんですよとに
スマブラもずっとやってるから
はーい
いっちゃ水の700万人
今そうですね700万にそうですね
こないだ300万人かそうですねまぁどう
にか持った方にこう寄り添えるように
頑張らないとなっていう
10ん
入らないか調べずに
次にとって頭の動画映る取れましたねなん
かすごいなんかずっとなくてございますよ
枝はなんかあの感じにこんな風に撮影する
とこがもうなかったんでここさえなんか
ちょっと前の youtube に戻った
感じがしますがね息抜きになります
ネチャネチャ
助かりましたよね家ばかりどんどん出て
くるからねそうですねいろんなスタイルが
できたんだよん
そういった意味ではなんかめちゃくちゃ肩
の力抜いて撮影できたいい
めっちゃ楽しかったも2あと家でが好き
です
あっなんすかね
山よりもあのいいえていうかすぎるする
パスがに
ようやくに2日前に稼ぐという大内そこが
決めたねっているそうですねこの間ポップ
なかったんですよ僕があるあっ
秒なくとってよね捕まえに初めてシャワー
を浴びてええええ
出力達成したあったあれ怖いっすよね5
ちょろちょろと地別のネットはただ1曲を
修理していた
緑なぁの道の女郎日で年2月7日となって
いる
ほんとマジでありございますが早いっすね
はなかったねーちゃくちゃなかったですね
最後のラストスパートめちゃくちゃピンク
色しょん
皆さん他技術にありがとうございますが
出力まずありがとう a
もうこれからを絶対多分走り続けていくん
だろうと思ってますのではいまだまだ
ちょっと先を見させていただこうかなん
最近ちょっと一緒に運動する機会があった
んですけどゴルフ東亜
2人と分マン千鶴風バッハなくてるッ
主役が何たいですぼく今27スクリーン
80ですね今ここに入ってくるんですよ
いやマジで動けなくなです
視座からな変なもしのな木組みだっひい
いいいいてなる左膝
沈没しそうだ
kreva ゴルフとねーどほんと分する
ウットパフィッシャーズと弾み冊
どんどんこれから
32近づくわけですけれども
そう考えるとその中で課金さん
30個入ってさんはそうそう
頑張られているの本当にすごいなっても
絶対寝てないです
右手ないかめちゃくちゃ寝ている方にあっ
客覚醒してるんですけどにも常に見えてる
見ておりますそれじゃあ怖いなそれ
無意識だからやれてるみたいな
ルーティン化セミナーすごいよー4位
戻すには出たいと思ったかな
確かも負担ソロです
ない帰ったの一緒に歳も近いした郊外へと
youtube ショーに行ってきてるか
ん
受賞か下げては俺たちももう3使いなって
いっ
詐欺もう太鼓台だ裏出しましたね
いやヴェイドいっ
ブーブー
[笑い]
s
worth 殺すぞ
俺ございますありがとう
3ください
まあ1万人超えてるよ
不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
不
線
ありがとうございますみなさんありがとう
ございますちょっとでバディーさん呼び
たいんだよね
2人とも来てくださいますかね
そうあの
止めてありがとう
[音楽]
何かさあその
どうしてもらう
そのどうしてもさ俺ちょっと感謝したい人
がいます
あうすと今
外っていうか柄せい
が映りはしないですか
そうですよねっ
ほんとっ
何でしょ
なんか今だから言うんですけど
マディって呼ばれるう部のマネージャー
してください人は可能なビール釣れますね
なんかブームのバディっていうミーハー
ミディアムことをしてくださる方がいるん
ですけど
なんか
本当にそう月動画を
[音楽]
取る動画撮ったり減衰すると海外版と何も
出来なくている
すごい
なんか忘れ物とかも多くて
しれません
宇部市変わったられるん
猫がせるボード某規定
なんか
案件の撮影とかも
長日とか前日に急にこれは嫌でこうしない
ですとか
[音楽]
あのん
準備してくださるんですよ大がかりな撮影
の時とか
[音楽]
抜かそういう僕の
わがままに
[音楽]
の理由さーわー
なんか文句も言わず
ズーム考えてくれるんでー
本当に関節てて
なかなかこういう機会までと言えないので
ちょっと言葉を借りて撃っ
本当にありがとうございますって言わせて
いただきます
ありがとうございます
移り家でたよ
見てる人には伝わらないんですけど
[音楽]
本当に
なんかあまりに言うとフリッパは散っ
ちゃうんですよ僕
したいことがはっきり言っ
はっきりというかつたいことがあっ
したいことをするために本当にいろんな人
を振り回しちゃってて
たくさん迷惑をかけてるんですけど
が応えてくれている
いてくれて
1000万人これたのかなと思っています
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
ミュートスタッフも呼びますあのー
受けてもするなと言ってたんですよねー
ちょっとコメントみようかな米酢分のは
なぜ
本当に迷惑かけて俺めっちゃ迷惑かける
良いとに
もうほんと分こうやって結果が出ないと
まずで笑えないよ
そのマネージャーなんとかスタッフとかも
信じてついてきてくれてると思ってるん
ですよ
ちゃんとこうやってテープが出て
実は安心しています
[音楽]
うどんどすよ
ちょっと嬉しいいるカードで食べる部分ん
火事でアクセルからスパ付てたまあ嫁が
なかったかったんですよね
どうぞどうぞ入ってください
を詐欺は良いはちょっとお酒喰種術
no o
[音楽]
朝てくださいです
web
amaran
に入るかな
大寒すまん本当にしてっだけどあのみょ
覚えのある人もいると思うんですけども
ここにいる
金助等
面白い顔が切りつけていうのに白い顔でお
願いします
と今畑から弾み雪をの裏方に
来てくれているよう平郡島
って言うと
あなた誰ですかね
お前さぁサーフィンという
後輩なんですけど
ちょっとこの場を借りて今この3人等
あと
もう一人変数している後輩の
以前ですよなんか本当は今日もアン型の
編成があって
だよ元せなんですけど
どうしてもやらなきゃいけないにも強がっ
て
それも今頑張って誰がやってると思うん
ですけど
裏でそうやって頑張ってくれる誤配がい
たり
12月はこの3人と大地くんと支度とで
ほんとっ
んですけどか
サーブに通してはん
ごめんいつもを作りますじゃあもう
[音楽]
というか
みんなさあでも綺麗に選んだですね
[音楽]
ほんとそれはお礼で回れていいんだけど
我が名が体
いろんな後半振り回したり
前ラーメンいこうとか音声の音が入っても
いい
注ぐ来てくれたりそれだけじゃないんです
けど
もう
さっ
のカメラとか
こういうの巣てほしいとかここまでいき
たいとか車出してくれたり
な事すてっぷれてい
4へぐも
畑から来て狂っじゃないですか
頭狂白色酒で強けりゃいいねひとりごちを
続けている
窯変くんの今畑
1人ずつ変わっててそのはず1パック
[音楽]
掃除機を異性たくて畑にも弾み冊を
の宇田ってどうなってるんだろうとかもぅ
叩きにも今全然出てなくて
they てないなりの理由もやっぱすっ
てほしくて
1人ずつ肇社長の裏方として今洋平くんで
やってもらってるんですけど
1000万に行くまでは
予約ももう山でもするってくるてー
抗菌性とかのれ投したりー
がありえない時間に撮影協力とかしても
ラップでしている
ここまでこれたのはう
[音楽]
イントっ
一大地くんと今編者している後輩見てるか
な見てる
2人増えてる
上に4だけだったけど
津浦でお俺ともう一人品そしてくれた人が
いて
ちょっと12月は俺はこのメンバーで人馬
っていうのがあるんですけど
兄ちゃんでのそこで
がんばれてくれた方っていう
します
頑張りだかないのにウズらしく仲がいい
ですね俺ないとを経て解ければなんでー
よくっ
[音楽]
混ぜてみたなぁ
珍しいというですよねー
一番ドッキリしかけちゃうんですよ
西中
[音楽]
役所の言い分
どうぞ
yahoo
何ドッキリできるかって
などリアクションがイースいい
そこはゲイすれば人の良さ目あのー
可哀想ってならないよ
ちゃんと笑ってくれるから
ん
よそれすごいやる側からしたら第二出
たーーーーー
可哀想って人に全然時したくないんじゃん
e 車ちょっと方を払っておりますね
はだけ
その中
数がちゃんと
なんか
悔しがる強く寄せ合ったり怒ったりして
くると
っていう
約束してくれる
系好きに
ベンチャーでがすごい助けられたのですよ
思っん
[音楽]
どれだサーブ
ここ最近すごい
一緒にいるけど
[音楽]
最初は
なんかよなかったって行くラーメン行く
じゃないですし差分
本当に3時とか認証がに呼ばれて
やっぱなし科に行ってるんですけど
めっちゃ都合のいいやつにだよいう感じ
ずっとと思われると思ってたけど
最後西国で5歳ラーメンた時に
[音楽]
は13友達もいて
源さんとなっちにをご紹介してもらった
ように
[音楽]
病んでる時にあじゃさんが病んでいると
くんです
一緒に
一緒にいてくれるんだよねみたいなんです
ね
言われてるん
すごいホッとしたというか
何ですかめっちゃ
[音楽]
使われてるわけじゃないんだなみたいなん
です
利用されていると思ってが悪いない庄司値
は2アーサーねそうだなんか
感じに思われてるんだと思ってる
[音楽]
根崎と悪いやつみたいなったですねちゃん
ちょうどを楽しくて言って出す冗談でも
いい
[音楽]
で一番サウナ
一緒に行くのサーブどのさえちん
でもで呼ぶのって
居心地がいいからであって
6サーブのそういう
を使いやすいところとか
ね突っ込んだよ
本当は2人で行ったらいいですね
ゲストサービスする
惨つの良い部分があるからん
よく一緒に最初はイルカなさるという夫婦
助かったよ
[音楽]
そう月12月1000万人行きたいですっ
てからもうメンタル過疎地不安でルー
怖かったんすよね時旅行
その音が本当にちょっとした時間にいて
くれたりしてい
つくばれますねこれはー
ネットサーだけ
[音楽]
100はどうでした桜
いやあのー
僕も最初なんかちょっとネガキャンから
入って申し訳ないんですけど
空寒締めくんやっぱり最近畑に出れなかっ
たっちさき混じると言ってましたん
だけ忙しいの生死が持ったつ
[音楽]
で実際こうやって裏方に入ってみて
フーガこの人ってすごいそのタイトな
スケジュールの中で寝る間も惜しんで0
自分が撮りたい動画映画にもいろいろな道
が分からなきゃいけないじゃいけないん
ですよまっ
もう体力すごいしケーブル xvc 今年
はちょっと畑
に例え出れなかったとしても
[音楽]
の言わず生死一
思って
まただ主事こうやって1000万円迎え
られ
本当に
なんていうかな楽器の自分も嬉しいが
china 東都不ショップなセンスけど
ん山八かですっごい
環境の中で
うん
いつも動画では彼から多分画面の向こうの
皆さんってどれだけ裏で忙しいかっては
なかなかわからないと思うんですけど
ユーチューバーう
あのん
はじめの裏殻に入ってみてわかりました
すごい year
忙し
なり花が小さいん
あれですチリ仕事してくれたからめっちゃ
助かったんですよねじゃないさ
あれなんですけどすごいですよ始めた人の
裏方のプレッシャーって
本膳永続本当に
あの
本当にねえええそれしていないですけど
りっ
俺はやりやすかったて普通にが使った恭平
君が裏にいてくれている
の中で仕事しているんだろういい
強欲なくなったんですよ本当に感謝ねない
すごすぎてお金これなんか見てる人らする
と急に出てきてなんだみたいなっちゃうん
ですけど俺はもう12月
図1月か
ここ1か月間は本当この人たちに助けられ
て
心も救われて
万実とか
ティック
済みな作業とか
多かったと思うんですけど
いろいろ本当文句言わずやってくれて
でもおかげで俺は一銭も大事だと思ってい
ますネタが進めると思いますえっ
[音楽]
1回1月に
前日の暴力行こう
体が無いさぁ触れたとおりますし本当に
ありがとうありがとうございます
始め9敗ここでちょっと僕たちから
プレゼントかいいえ
面倒見てもいいですかと思います
[音楽]
平和良かったので
まずの月例しますさあここ
されていん
僕たちから
マジっすかない伊勢マニー
おりますよねありがとうございます
尾藤嫌だいそうです
でかいああ
なんかもうほんと逆とか一切なしであっと
いうふうにウォーズマジで応答依存2月月
ちょっとよありがとうございません
ひっかけているからでもじゃあ今こそ
nico nico ありません
大丈夫破産してない
本番1消えませんだっハードはけどして
おります
オープン
てあげるねー
そうまずらーすごいもう恒浩様の声ます
どうやろ7新潟のみんな去っているてくれ
なかった
今回は感じ方から2実はから
えっこれからね上野まだ寒い地域は続く
から私がに
ありがとうございます
ぬるい
まず幸雄氏
頭狂
これちまう卒でて殺されたりあとあるわけ
ですテーマにいたというパッド
出てこちらうん
[音楽]
何これ入っ
下部からのかと彼らの
クララのクールを
これも
[音楽]
硬い方や位からなぁ
ありがとうございまーさーいっができませ
ん
家内からもおまけ的なあー
おおーー
日どんどんサングラスのもサングラス45
あれは大豆の某横います対応や憩いあっ
はぁ
蒼井優中だから
塗りがとー
やっぱりねあの23中なるじゃん確かに
やっぱりこう
おしゃれは小物からっていうか貸すかね
うん
ささないさん一つが実はこれもちょっと
入れてるんですよ戦略よりブッチャー本当
にふざけたわけで行っちゃっ本当にだけ
じゃないか new girl さんここ
がで押されになるとこうなっちゃうんです
よ付けてるわけじゃ以上8 e 1らー
んっ
事故ってふざけてるんじゃなく選んだけど
てくださいありがとうございに入っ
ねまったくなんかもしれなかったけど
イェイ後に真面目に選ばんでいただけまし
たありがとうないつくもうよく戻ってきて
くるからもう本当に
もっとのこの瞬間に立ち会えて
本当にもう
過ぎても同じ関西でこういう時には
ちょっとをつけたんですそう緊張したんだ
けど
ありがとう9 name
[音楽]
も読めない
もうやめない絶対辞めない
が道ああ
んだ本当にこのメンバーと本当にまあ
[音楽]
本当にも帰って抜けて編集があったんです
けど
やってくれてる後輩が1人艇
ここで一致団結するというか
ほんといつもママの上に築いてくれたこと
[音楽]
よかった結果が出てそれが一番これで
わがままでみんな振り回すて結果出さない
と本当に折れたらの悪い奴だから
ちゃんと出して俺はすごいひょっとして
ますにも
撮影地は
[拍手]
ちょっとー
向かせの頃とそこは変わったね
いろいろな人と協力して
雇っていっ
守らなきゃいけないものも増えて
1000万円一過程ですー
昔ば一人でね散歩のめっちゃだって適当
だった社の創始開けるのっち8月のためら
とって会みたいなん遊び感覚でやっていた
ことがねえ
今や本当にちゃんと
いろんな人を
東協力して
れることになって釣っ
プレッシャーもあるけどこういう嬉しさも
あるなっていう
感じです
いやほんといくわけじゃないですかね
ほめる人ちょっと形がルーキー
なるべく静かにしとこうと思いませんよ俺
本当やれとみんな nars ん
ちょっと爪にこれでまだ終わりじゃないん
で俺たちは
やり千万兄いくまで頑張ろうという感じで
ちょっとドイツ気象高原でやってたと思う
んだけど
俺はこっからだと思ってるからん
これからも引き続きよろしくお願いします
よろしくお願いしますそうあのついてき
ますねありがとう
とりあえず1000万人でこれ
しかしの某
その付でも入ってから今年の目標は達成し
ますそうだね
元なもんだよねキュア丸めてもらったらが
わかればそのってずっと言わですねえっ
雪花ダイヤモンド竪堀やすごいですねー
ありがとういっあーちょっと物に年内は
撮影続くと思うんですけども引き続き
よろしくお願いしまーす
ございますます
はいはいそれは氏は73でます
この際ん
すごい区の藤井よね
県のスタッフの皆さんでしたーー
本当にお世話になっ
朝がチェックダイヤバンドの他てもらえる
じゃん
作れますかねえ
わからん
ごめんちょっとね宇宙のが流通になてって
いうかこれだけほんとにちょっと感想を
伝えたくてこの場でしいろんな人に
協力してもらって
1000万人を達成できたと思います
結社が止まりません
[音楽]
えーと今も全然付いた見てないもん
今どうなっている twitter
となってねームスクながー
終わる事言ってる
難しいこと言うねえ
でもさ本当にごめさっきの話戻るけど
ダイヤ0
ダイヤを立てて所退場だねぇまたあなた
さあ畑100万に行った時に金の立って
もらったじゃないですかラーメン屋さんに
置いてやべっ
ダイヤモンド黒ねうそっ
どうすれよ+か塗って金の壁鉄筋のた課金
など金の盾俺近所のラーメン屋さんに置い
てあるんですよねっ
運営側のなんかラーメン屋さんのさ
いつも行くさーんプーさんの1000万に
頑張って言ってさあ行くたびに入ってくれ
て
うんすごいいろんな人に応援されている
なって改めて robots フレンドが
すごい
当たり前のことしか出て来ないんですけど
ねその当たり前がすごい幸せだなって
トレンド1位今もそう言っ
[音楽]
貼っなかった
何が来たみたいですを使い作るかも
みんなをならもうちょっと
余韻に浸らせてくださっ
歴史が長いからねぇ
[音楽]
ありがとうみんな愚民党
まで比較等になってるん
例えば企画が開いてましたハッハー
part 84
負けるで地下にダイヤだらけの超巨大な
マグマの湖はすんじゃないもの発見が低く
等でございますダイヤの館とかけてるかも
しれないハンマーいいよ前崎操作する
帰化議員さんがあっ
もやし本当におめでとーってきている
1斤もやしいっていうあんまりはれてない
よね太ったんですよ
太ったっていうか
がっちりしてるってたぜ筋トレしてからや
フレームが良くなってるんですねほんとに
羨ましい席から見ると自分声も
はっはっはそう筋肉ついたいうん
[音楽]
それさん来ないかな来るわけないですよ
ここ
期間さんとブームは敵同士なんですかで
ございません
1コ
ツっ
ラーもて来い1000万人行くよ
動い
ありがとうございます
見て皆さんありがとうございまーす本当に
みつぐに行ってよここで急に上げだ
スタッフ5倍なシーンだけど家帰っ
[音楽]
昔が懐かしいねぇ
どうですか皆さんどういう動画を
めぐっ
記憶にあります
弾み社長といえばなぜ結構いろんな動画
とってきたからさー
ひとによって弾み冊はコレって色が違っ
たりするよ
[音楽]
ない次は何ですか津波に
発目社長といえばみたいな
やっぱりスライム風呂じゃなるの
[音楽]
頼むって本当大変目3 a
よく分かりましたこの二日前ぐらい
皆さん本当1000万人さんは教育と思っ
てなかったかなぁ
結構まだ1000万に行くまで頑張るず級
の道だしばらく続くんですよ明日以降ぜひ
あの今チャンネル登録してくださった方
引き続き弾み撮像の方が楽しむって
くださいしますはい
まで2番行くよこれ
にまいりましたーーー
ありがとうございます
えっ
はいなビルなっ
冷凍たち皆さん本当に
あっ
ガチャリー
you to bar の大学うわ夏か外
待ってくださってるぞ
ちょっと待ってくださいよ
ちょっと待ってくださいよはいぞ
彼母
熱い発砲されますいやーすごいねー
壁たぬきましたーーー
ございますぅ
いやーすごいは是非大三角どこか分かって
ます分かってなかった空名誉
ピッっ
きって大丈夫なんですよ俺は神だよねそう
そうだと止められませんですよ
全然2位の日本まり快く受け入れたか
素晴らしいジムじゃなところあって食った
ん
ありがとうございますけどございます
ございますであの1000万円綺麗です
プレゼントえっ
この
さああ一人じゃなくなぁそうホラーウィン
ジョブヤッター
ポリじゃあの真の音とお揃いやんだった
アルア
ono shape
スパッ
派より厚者さんとねー
すごいなぁ4本針
ありがとうございます
いやー
の最後に解散とあったんですよね
すごいほんま最近あって言ったって動画
強硬化されているあ添えて今日はやはり
さん他の動画もすごいタイミングだったん
だと思っ
マジだね
素晴らしいなぁ
1000万人け
加部さんのおかげも結構デカイと思います
野志社会全然
一市長の全て力いやいやそんなことない
ですよ
ありがとうございますか
かわいい創賜
ね
あっ1回売れねーほんとリピくださると
思っています一応その中配信なんとなく
椅子もなんか結構アバウトたってんこの日
かこの日かも見たい
プーさんにもいつお伝えしてたんですけど
すごいタイミングデー
水田はリバウンドからぼっちだったよね
そうなんですかねそう
あいつらー
撮影人いいです
いなかったら
ここ3年で今日のドラマは今日が見て
下さい日からサブとに関しては
すごい汗ばいいねこれでも一銭も入って
からだいぶ経ってもたちが結構経ってます
ねー
さぁゲームなぁとどれくらいでいっと
あと間違っにペンライトってますね歴史的
ような
いやありがとうございます本当に取れの
位置だったしなんつったというと1ねっ
すげーなほんまりう
ありがとうございます昨今になっ
客さんかっこいいですよあっはぁ
ああああああ阿部さんのブームにいうのが
ずっと衝撃的てきてる発ですモハ2ので
きっちり頭を打ちましたあっひっチリ
カメラましたからだからその歴史的瞬間は
カメラに収めて1000万年もすごいでき
的だと思うんですけどひかりさんがルーム
に知っている紐を設置してるいやーもう
ほんまれだって1巻第からですよねー
そうレイヤーなフェアですよ本当に
殺気立っていっ
絶対俺のチャンネル2ライト処理
焼き付ける
一人だけ地点ああそうねそう
確かにそう
からもうなんか変な感じになる
確かになかっ
そこつなげてわけじゃないんですけど
両方と関わりのある人ってけっこうべ r
前ん
ほんま理想
いやーいいなぁなんかおめでたいな純数に
その
なんていうかな
お祝いできるもん
いやーありがとうヒットとかそういうのは
全くなくすごいなと思い
かぶさんって結構素直ですよ
ああもちろんもちろん夏目はつ言いたい
ことを言ってしまうと優しくんですかね
すごいとこだって俺も8年やっておかない
とね1000万人いかに難しいかっていう
のわかる c
8年継続する地帯や花ん長いですよね
軽さもかなり生地はここからまだ続くわけ
そうですねそう考えたラップすごいなっ
買い手はなっ
youtube の歴史ダーム浅いけど
そこの youtube 流ればとてつも
ない会系なんじゃない
ありがとうございます
ございますね
ひかるさんの僕にはまだここから来年
私がや僕たちには大きな使命が残されて
いるいやデカすぎる
起こされた使命がちょっとでかいねほんと
に次回プレッシャーも願いしな
ちょっと今日の動画で光さんの撮影にも
喬木度はコラボとが上がっています理由
ちょっと
大変は近くさんと僕の
動きに注目していただけると月ありがとう
ございお願いします
異性マンに入ったからといって全然止まら
ないので
ちょっとこれからもぜひ宜しくお願いし
ますコメントありがとうございます荒れ球
して過ごされてましたございましたーーー
ありました
ミザリー温度は呼んでくれまあをねます
俺の犬だったねっ
そうなんすかん三つ葉上では延長してるん
びっくりしたーー
本当に聞き作ればいいよねぇ
したのか
浦和いただきましたありがとうございます
すごいなんか売れで対日んのイメージだっ
たから性能
二見追うなっている
[音楽]
ほんとありがたいですね色んな
youtube さん
けどもう
いろんな人の
おかげといったんですけどもスクリー
たーーーー様もつろんで
本当にいろんな人に
強力というわけで受け力を合わせあって
動画作ったり
日影さんて髪の毛特徴的なって性格が
わかりやすいザカリ様というか
メサのですごい好きなんだよ
ほんとも今年
光さんに多さになったん
1年でした本当に
スマホ州の方
またです
[音楽]
大家さんから前もって貯めるはっはっは
すごい多い版所でリっこれっ
もう
待って
終え増税わー
あああん
そして冬眠
こんなことちきなよ
米は高岡消せます願っていません
した目指すよございます
この堀
言っちゃいけないんじゃないよませ
よく帰ってきたよございます
母児ですおめでとうございますおめでとう
ございますそうなんだけど
富が帰ってきたのが嬉しい
まあ橋是非取り組んだよねうん
多そうですねなぜ一番
連絡くださっ別物への旅ごめんねーな
カラーミンクいいとか言って取り上げる
いやんもう
水たまりモンドマジでこの期間
一番支えてもらった3位8位
ソースの完成
復帰後初めて会うのがこの一戦はぞ
ありがとうん
今復帰して初めて会ったんですよとミット
そそうですよね
ありがとうんにー
らじおんわざわざ静岡から来ていただい
たり飛ばしがにとに入っ
都民の代わりに頑張ったよろしいですか母
そうですよねそうですよ本当に
プリズムグッズのプーピー奴奴奴グッチ1
回なくなっちゃうっに20
くださっ日
4階でございました嫁がときってくれるん
ですよねよねこの際はそんな風に言っ
間に過ごすメモやー
千万でてい今何人なんですけどいま何人で
ますかねさてコメント店でちゃったんです
よ
一戦2万1千人でいます v
マジで僕らはいちまるきゅう
源さんのシリンダーがあったん
の時に二人で見に行ってこういう人が
ユーチューバーから出てるんだっていうの
で頑張ろう
ヤマメ
夢みたいですもが
ありがとうございますこれだけ
ここから登りかつすごい
魚のリオワークふと見やるじゃないブーブ
ネットワークだった山張ってそうですね
初めてはあの50人でババ抜きのババヌキ
画像チャンネル名さを覚えるががんばつ
贅沢じゃそうですよね気づいたら一緒に
動画とってたっていう感覚だから
すごいよ
だからちょっと待ってねやばい
発生した版は一さんの角煮豚ひぃっ
ないったらいやああああっっっ
北野武ですすいません
ブーブー言っ
なってその涙はいません
この波です雪舌打ち始め3知らなきゃいけ
ないね泉北ちょっとすっ推薦ってられるよ
ね
ちょっと全然違いとやっちゃってるなぁ
あっ入ってはちょっと強テーマで全然ない
ぞんですねうんやり橋デー
4弾めっちゃ優しかったんで
飲茶され庁舎はこの痴漢
[音楽]
ねえパンツ経済すせお祝いに来ねぇ
ちょっ
なんかすごいなぜなこと言っていい
やっぱり突っ込みじゃんとに行きたい
ポジションがあっ
突っ込む人ってさ
そう10:00何かがあったかさ
突っ込まれても貼ってなるからすごい立場
でが難しいというこという
[音楽]
罪に全角記号でも作ってくれるから
動画の中で
やっぱすごい本人の中で酔いづらいとか
[音楽]
気持ちの整理がつかずとか
どぉすればいいんだろうっていうのは出て
あったと思うから
すごい俺が先輩です
しちゃったうっていうこの期間何度もね
ぼくまあトミーが家出なかったっていうの
もあるんですけど何度も大きい僕のこと
いいんでも
そういう話もすごいしてもらってたんだよ
ほんと僕も支えられたました
簡単に関数の動画とってなくても作るから
ですねはあああ
して上でもやっぱ
ホっぽくなくするのがいいかなと思って
そう言うと日にふざけて何3倍クエとか
ないんだ
よかったよいや由来すいません
大プッシュございましたブーブー
お祝いしたい気持ちいいよああ
ああもっ
た言葉がいい
ずっと1000万に入っても引き続き俺
頑張ろうと思っているからさ
そうなの
これからよろしくなのですけれども
とんでもない人の背中を追っていたうん
一番
いろんなクリエイターさんいるけど
一番初め冊を好きだなって思うドリフト例
だと思っている実はここはうれしい
本当に走ってうれしい
ソースよだああああ
[音楽]
めっちゃ恥ずかしい事でちょっとけどでも
なんかこういう機会だからしかないけど
0分ですすごいうれしい俺は
少しずつ
レーザーずっと郵送ですっ
うっはっはーんっ
の部分に入っ
真ん中んつあったジュ役達成したみたいな
んですよ
ブーバーしたみたいな
2 j それ
これから行かないよねほんとでございます
僕らも頑張ります
これからも仲良くよろしくお願い社員です
濃密な本気モードでしてあがっ車
謎かに過ごせなく地球やっぱ本当に住む
ハンド動画でめっちゃ行きましょうあなた
がこれ本当に入ったスッキリの気をの動画
でしょうと思ってたからそうですよねくっ
ありがとうは内田決めて
今はリボンどうでしたーー
たぶんなんだけど一番俺のこと好きなの
水玉リボンどないっ呉昇桓3 a 棟
本当に何故かそこはね自信持っている
かな
長いいい
期間いろんなクーデーターさんと
[音楽]
ニュードしてきたんですけど
すごかったねと身が入ってきて
[音楽]
なんかすごいいろんな人来てくださるね
本当に
入ったみお
今だ
塗ってるから走っ場でトレード
あーだねぇ
乗ってるのってますね今ってすごくの2万
件のツイートされています
皆さんありがとうございます見れるかなぁ
ことですね
皆さんまだ日本のトレンド1位です
今ちょっとカメラを合わせてもらってい
ますございますはい
今一祥を目指す2000番20902付の
ツイートで
日本の酉の市にありがとうございます
ここから誰が来るんですよねー
また来てくれる可愛いコキってくれる前提
に見たになってるけど
本当にビザ間にボンドとかしっかりさんと
か言いませんで来てくれたからね
[音楽]
大家さん大家さんに強く相当ますそこでだ
大家さんもねすごいお世話になってるし
ねー脳やん
あの家は本当に
大家さんと電話してみますかね
でるかな
[音楽]
まあをつけさまでですご唱和いっ
あー聞こえて来て者を築けそうです
ないっかいきました磯パワーもめでとう
ございますねございますえっ
はっはっちにその電話ですねありがとう
ございました
広がったとクリス前で確かにクリスマスの
前日ですねもねえなんかすることあったか
なんでもオーバーくださいあっ原さんやね
はいありますからなどをや長野おうちで
ここまでこれたと言っても過言ではないの
で
ええいいその畑だあのなんかも使って
くださいオレが持っていてくださいはーい
おめでとうございます
ああよかったありがとうございますはーい
大家さんと今も連絡とってるよ
本当に方
高中いないよねあんなりいいねん
[音楽]
普通バーって大変なのっていう
マンションとが進めたさあやっぱ声出すと
苦情来たりするんですよ
チェッコそこで苦労されている
ユーチューバーさんとか多いと思う
本当に恵まれた環境でここまでこれたかな
と思っています
[音楽]
29:45だ
はせべメッツいろんな人からを見にとって
きている
[音楽]
ありがとうみんな
勇太さん来ている本当にっ
[音楽]
してさっきさあトレンドの上にあったんだ
けどさー明日呪術快晴の映画始まる俺も
ずーっと気になってたそれにたいわー
[音楽]
持っていく話ん
うわ流す発で監督さんという方が
いらっしゃるんですけど
3万円スパしてくださっく満足されると
思いもありがとうございます
[音楽]
おじいさんおめでとうございまーさーああ
ああ一斉もめでとうございます
ああいやどもっぽいのです
[音楽]
ブーバ増加はってロサ手を組んでちょっと
今日来なかった行カセットは0皆さん
よくみたいな元気ですからねまあテロ君は
早い方だけどこの人この一年ああ
合わせ西軍がスポーツしてくれると言って
たので本当にずっと大尽くすパター北的お
願いします
nedo 人旅やおめでとうございます
そんなに1000万人
マジですごい
ぜひスカイピースも今年ちょっと400万
人ずっと目指して走ってきたのでやっぱ
その数字を目指す大変サテン2わかるので
いい
結構さあ
精神的にきつくなかっ
邪鬼ですね
だからも編集とかも線しなきゃいけないし
あと目標を掲げているから行かせないとっ
ていうプレッシャーもあるじゃないですか
つって大変ですよね
仕組みです
ちょっとー
結構でかくてちゃった語った970万人で
残り1か月だったからうわぁすっか一日
一万人は
増えないといけないつそうですよねー
30は方へんだわー
封筒
なんか自分の中では戦ってたああ
すごいなぁ
観察で保守調査が皆さんにあったり
実は結構一さんと俺
スマブラーやる中だったりします
意外といえば動画では出てないじゃん
難しく確かに動画では全ずに普通に
プライベートでそのブラシたりとかするん
意外と絡みあるんだよっていう確かにね
言うと知られてないのかな
そうですよねたぶん一切出してない積んだ
よしかっ
実は仲いいんですよ実は中によ
朝にはもうちょっとええそうですよねー
ちょっと遊び行ったときちょっとじゃあは
1回なんかあげましょうするため画像とか
今回ですねちょっと一さんにプレゼントが
あります実感
閉じた先
そうですよねー
ブースに見てましたあそこ同じだって思っ
たパンッ
でも大きさすぐ西そう
だねそれは上なん子じゃない
こちらよかったら
それぞれます神ターン
理由ます
えっなにこれ
記憶の顔写真とかだったらちょっといや
大丈夫ですなぜちゃんといい奴です本当に
入っします
なんだ
[音楽]
meありがとうございますありがとう
ございます
いやー
次しておけるにもねそうですまあこれは
何かと言いますとあの
これこうだったハウスにある
あの昔一さんがどうかで仁丹といじって
くれたら緩みなるじゃないか人体の
ぬいぐるみだこれそうでゆき坊のなので
あのあげちゃってたんで写真で残しておい
てもらいたいなということで持ってきます
めっちゃにいけないこれでもジャッキー
さっうわぁ凄い
はっはっは
待ち受けてい
[音楽]
天霧にあげちゃったんですよねそうですよ
ねあっちは使ったさ待ちつつ塗ったの
なんか嬉しそうに動画でも持っていたから
うれしかったありがとうございプレゼント
をとらせていただきますこれはウチも
それっぽい走行表に出してくるなぁあとで
銀貨ですお願いしますね前回のあれ
ということで言うよえっとスカイ p さあ
ですねんまぁ
重いデーのユーチューバーと言いますかな
この出来事出来事を決行
思い出と考えてて
なんで今日この瞬間をちょっとチェキの
5000円をぜひ
敵を討ってきますなぁ
本当なん
さ大事そうに焦げていてちょっとこれ
どなたかチェキトラトって頂く事って可能
だったりしますか
od です無理かーしゃ先端うえらう
の前
ああ
ここをしたらできるので
ミュート人だ本当にやもう全然ですよね
急がせんちってたからちょっといやもう
全然もいつでも書き込みますから手を組ん
でいるので
がいきますよ
はいっ
がぁりがとうございません
うわぁ
ミュートずんだあんいやもう本当にまた
遊んで下さいあそぼん遊びたいですまだ
から1000万人入ってちょっとは気が楽
だったじゃないですかたぶん
結構楽にあったなりましたね
だからね落ち着いた時にご飯行きましょう
いきますのでぜひ
ほんとだ
仁丹はねぇ過去の話でいると思う
もう多分
そんなこともあったなーって思うかと思い
ますはいですけど第腎臓した時がありまし
て僕わー
あったなぁ施工はいちょっとそれはそれが
あるうーんばいけないうんなのであるん
ですけど
雷神図した時に
神たがめちゃくちゃ早く
[音楽]
[笑い]
そうなんですよもう
実は僕も昔似たような炎上をしたことが
ありません
他人事じゃなかったんですよ
うえらうすごい親身になって
9 s 新聞になってあんまりそん時に
なったんだからそうですよねー
その時にもう雨にも他人事じゃなさすぎて
長文でラインも持ってなかったああそうだ
dm で送って
[音楽]
どけ機を持ってくださいを作ってん
ゆっこに救われましたらいやそうですよ
ねー
そうですよねもおかしいですか
そうですよでもおかしいんだん
そういう実は仁丹ははじめシャツを抜いて
い
裏で結構仲良かったり支えてもらったり
じゃあそうなんですからです実は
この前でいうとあれですからねあの
ユーチューバーから送られてくる
プライベート動画でグランプリ取って
もらったあっ俺
相馬さん通るで4ねええええ
これ来年も優勝したいですがやっぱり結構
でメタか言われたかですって
絶対視聴者には受けない動画であるんです
よいろいろ失う花を使ったんですけどこれ
からもちょっとねグランプリを目指して
来年頑張りたいと思いますよね僕も
ちょっと頑張りましょうはいありがとう
ございますありがとう次長期滞在
ありがとうございますさあいったんでした
ありがとうございまーさーああ
じゃあするします
こちらは上げます出たーーーーーい道楽
はいございます宇宙写真
8視聴者プレゼントさんハーイ
多い
視聴者プレゼントそんな
サイン会とか二人分飲んできますねー等
ありがとうございまーたさんていただき
ます失礼しますありがとうはおめでとう
ございはそんなに
いいし頑張って言われますありがとうだ
なっています例えば曇り時ね
ありがとう
そっかておく忙しかったかッ
ちょうどておくんからブラジャーが漫然
摘んできている¥49,800
¥49,800もううトーンという
0件
コメントを呼んでいいですか同じは切り
行けなくてすみません代わりに家の最高の
メガネ相方が深いピースの文王祝いしに
行ってくれました
何でも優しく無邪気な子供みたいな一さん
が大好きです
1000万人という大変な道のりをソロで
かき揚げが系駆け上がっていく姿に感動と
尊敬を受けました本当におめでとうござい
ます
ございますありがとうございます
今や道東くん
しか時物を受け取りましたん
ツ峰あさってくらいかな
ちょっとモテ男くんとあーちょっとこれは
また内装に仕上がったとこっておくんとの
動画がどこかでています
[音楽]
サム写真やばいよねああああっ
もっとたくさんのクリエイターさんに
愛せる愛されているというか支えられて
本当に1000万円でかなって思ってます
見難いなぁ
結構要因にしてありますねえええ
2人でコラム
いやもう一人たーーー
[音楽]
めっちゃコメント現在ごめんごめん
あゆーたさんからもいいね来てたらしい
u ターン
きてましたを多め
短期いくだけ
豊ありがとうございます
ぺるぺドに大目だけ
えっ
[音楽]
あげたいなぁ本当に
フィット3を
そんなが1000万に行くまでもさん
youtube のアプリビルのくせに
行っちゃってるつみつみ
思える時からずっと見てるとこっちが
すごい時々済みでドキドキする
こんな感じで配信されてるんだよ本当に
ユタさんありがとうございます
yuta さんはサイズスマグラー頑張り
たいといけません
[音楽]
と音楽音とたくさんの人が来てるなぁ
とありがたいですねぇ
goo
[音楽]
会社月連絡を
えっちゃんからも来てみたいないっちゃん
行っちゃうえっちゃ
[音楽]
なってきていません
茶やマダラコメントで変わったと a
ヴィッツの皆等
個人チャンネルで哲也さんがスポーツして
いるとまずちゃ
[音楽]
きんちゃんねる
まあそうさん
[音楽]
無双さんもいらっしゃいますよ
ほんとだまあそうありがとうございます
ご結婚おめでとうございます
[音楽]
東山堂最近部下だったなぁ
テツナから来てるんで作って
うわぁ
[音楽]
そうさんおめでとうございます
ありがとうございます本当にいい
[音楽]
出身マンに入った瞬間泣かない予定だった
んだけど
3回ぐらいのいけない入ってから3階の
異聞
1000万人ヒカキンさんと言います
はっはっは
てっつぁんのツイート見て徹夜もずーっと
見るネザー
いつやるん
[音楽]
あっははっはーん
思いの自分で追悼してましてですよ
[音楽]
5演説で見逃せだ挙筋さんがいるとさ
いらっしゃると冊とストキンさんを見たく
立つ
見えますかね
ここに入っ
鉄だが49,800円ここでマンドクセつ
しこれからも頑張るように上から
ありがとうございますけどさぁ
建造人みたいなので上から来ますねうっ
待ってくださいマジっすたぁ
うーんありがとうございます
エコばしーちゃんだってくださいまし
たーーー
ありがとうございますねっ
うんありがとうございます
今でしょうかっ
ありがとうございますありがとうござい
ます
花を頂いたよねー
今日はありがとうございます
[音楽]
超変わります
asondeいないところ誰か仕込んだ
これ
うまじすかちょっとってくださいよ
[音楽]
そうですよね
リアルございません
こばせ子さん向けの
流通バーの中のお水でございまして
肇社長が1000万円いく辛い時も
コバせるちゃんの動画を見て
頑張れたのねっ
来ませんじゃがいたおかげで1000万に
自分といってもいいですね
ブーブーだよ
えーっあっちゃん見せてくれてそれがえっ
なるほどくんぜひ過ごし来なかったですか
が年々
練習何度ですか
せてくれました
ですか
お水ですよねっ
ちょっと道がたくさんですねありがとう
まず本当に穂が見て癒されてるんだよね
また楽しむ女性いけないんだ頑張ります
パースに版頑張るいた訳
頑張ってくださいね
ありがとうござ頑張ります
上つ選んだ世界一はちょっと待って
[音楽]
すっごいかこんな感じなんですよいわゆる
と話すことがあっ
最近全然中ですか銀てぃんでほんとですか
おお
何か辛いこととかないですかねないんです
か
悩み事とかないん
今は楽しく
3000年あってあたりその同じです
ここは1階がないかが悩みだったんでつい
てたほんとって良かったねうん1実感
ぐらいかな
辻考えられない多分
そうだね1時間ぐらい
みたいな寿司がすごくと桜
パンツって
柴田話し合って太田レジン庁舎ねって本当
に
[音楽]
いやー楽しいことありましたね
ここ最近12月であ今年楽しかったことっ
[音楽]
イベントにでイクッんですよハイメガ
楽しかった楽しかったが良かったですよ
ええ
おこわ先生方も使ったらなんじゃないです
よ
[音楽]
緊張しちゃうんですよね本当にアヌ
結構
実はう女性としゃべれなくてほんとにっ
わかります
女性としてれない
2です女性と喋れないちょっと一年ません
あそうなんです
いやちょっと分かります何かのう
そうなんですよね僕に渡航同い年のどこが
いるんですけど
そのことを喋れないんですよね
緊張しちゃって
結構結構そうなんですよ
そこ原因かなという気もするんですけど
どんなのことしゃべるのがある
になってというか女のが好きなんですけど
と言うとなんか国でがあってください
対面の場にすると大竹喋ったと見てことを
ちゃんと女性と全然ないないでしょって
どんなボスキーですよ今なく大介
大がつくかね
頭骨しゃべれなくて
ちょっとこの戦って勝ったことの感じに
なっちゃうってもん
ホント昔から応援してます
応援してありがとうございます
を味方に音楽が止まっちゃったじゃん
ちょっと待って
空さんと日と罰
テントを
なんか
た次会った時にサッと ai しようと
すると結構量があると
向かっているこぼすにちゃんと撮りたい
動画があってちょっと連絡したんですけど
なんか話になっちゃったもあったですね
サーん
ちょっとまた機会があったら変活動に君の
姿をよろしくお願います
逃げられますよな
小橋さんでしたぁー
プレス
なっちゃうんですって本当に
なんで俺女のかされないかなぁ
なんか彼女とか
仲良くなったら仲良くなっているっていう
かちゃんとしたらしゃべれるんだけど基本
的にざっ性としゃべるのは苦手なんですよ
めちゃめちゃテーションあいました僕
スキル出向させる一番推しです
要素は何です
同じですね
私ちゃん来るのやばいっ8にヤバイって
いいって何よそれは売ってないよオレモー
びっクリスタナーありがとうございます
本当に
すごいいろんな人が来て下されますねえ
どれもだけで来るかわかんなくなってきた
よえっ
6作町からわかるみんな急いでと離せない
この
もどかした
[音楽]
寝付くまず寒そういやでそれがねなんか
こう
かっこつけてしゃべるしゃべるよって言う
んだけどあの実際は
同じ状況になると思う
[音楽]
何でなんだろう
モットーなるもしゃべれる
人間になったのかなぁ
わかる
鉄じゃあいるんじゃ先の49,800円も
スポーツして2ちょっとでついそして得て
います
なんでコイントスで今日もなかったん
ここで満足せずこれからも頑張るように
入っねあった
[音楽]
1家じゃなくて徹夜の彼女とコラボした
かッ
[音楽]
んですよみなさーん
大丈夫みんな木曜日にすみませんこんな2
おいでおほんとたくさんの方が来て
くださって面白いですね
ありがとうございますありがとうござい
ます
[音楽]
ています
おせません
故障し
待ってくださいん
持ってください社長ですか
はい
待ってください
社長なんかあのあ
1000万人おめでとうございますね山中
ありがとうございまーすちょっと待って
待って待って待って待って待って
あいやまだです
よく燃えないかと思っても社長社長はあの
なんか家建てたって
私を聞いて総湯3億円のうちょうを買い
まして
あ買ったんですか今更皆さん
結構アレしたちゃんとカフェとか頑丈な
ところが買いましたそうですね割とキック
壁とかは頑丈な気がしますみよう
ああそっかよかったよかった
じゃあちょっと鹿鹿あのございますね
日本の桜ですか
はい
なぜなにかされるんですけど
いやいや別に何もしあのあの御祝御祝に
行きますあっお祝いに来てくださる
山田エイプのぽられたら僕という怠慢と
打つと山田孝之が来たってツイートして
いいですか
どうぞ
過ごす一つぼっちで消せ
ときほど本当に前回あのね肇社長にあの
映画業界の未来を
大きく左右する救世主となっていただいて
まあしていますいいえこちらこそ本当に
ありがとうございますメガ質問コーナーで
フランスまで殴って本当にすみませんです
か
イェイ年前も oa でしたもうちょっと
できないんじゃ
あのねなのでまたちょっとその頑丈な家に
伺わせていただくので誕生で春を言えばお
祝いで羽化がして遠いはにゃありがとう
ございます山田でぜひ
ん
なんかすごいよ
1男まだまでやるんですかこれ
やっぱすごいたら試してますけどそうです
ね大駄作だよなんですか日々を作った
小さな子いたけどはい
ちょっと照れてるしていたしそういう意味
でねいいですよねそして可愛い形がからさ
れますながらさせません
でもおっしゃいますねはいよく山田孝之
さん
東電はできたのが一番今驚いています
まあまあの今度はまたの海綿体名しますね
ぜひ
早辻家と家に遊びにいらしてください
はいちょっとまあいろいろと準備していき
ますうわぁようでますちょっとくまいます
じゃあ本当にありがとうございます
ありがとうございます山田孝之さんでした
あだめよ車両を持ってくださいありがとう
ございますでしょうかな
ん
勇者よし行こう
またさゆきさんはエグいっ
今年の
9イベントだったもんねー
織田さんと質問コーナー
めちゃめちゃ面白かったもっ
アガサ本当に役者というかプロでも
るってなったら前でやってくださって
くるっ
すごいなって思うこれかっこいいハック
いいねぇ
コメント欄やまたターゲットさんかっこ
いいで埋め尽くされてちょっとやきもち
焼いたからあっはぁ
すごいなぁ
市中折ため画面ないか
はぁっ
を押します
というような出会いがあったね
今年も50年間も
[音楽]
一番ビックリしちゃったぞぅ
ふぅ
ほんとちゃんとツイートしてるぜ
山田孝之さんらが作ったから仕上がり一番
はやはり過ぎちゃうって
1ファンとしてね
[音楽]
びっくりしたぁーまだですかつありがとう
ございます一時まふくんすぎる
怖くない何か壁が壇上だからいきますって
おっしゃってました
そそういうことなんでそれだ農村が何吸っ
いい
あれかな
壁を開ければペタッ
暴れるって言う感じだっ大丈夫かな
ちょっと皆さん是非てもらった貝木さん家
に遊びに来てくださみたいなのでお楽しみ
に
すごいなぁかあの花花がその他いっ
ありがとうございます本当に
[音楽]
びっくりしちゃうね見てくださっている方
も
[音楽]
あまりものっ
が触れもうぞあの方も役者なんですよ
ちょっと切りちゃいましょう
読み手とありがとうございます
本当にありがとうございますみなさーん
[音楽]
正木に電話して馬崎はさ多分働いている
ようになっています
難しい気がするんだよね栄つの方はこの
木曜日の
平日の
初子とかどうなんだろう
[音楽]
true
あったいってそして未だに増え続けており
ますチャンネル登録者数
もう
24,000にチャンネル登録者数が増え
ていただいておりますありがとうござい
ます
皆さんまだ今窓口
あーた
未だについな
イイネ4まだまだ1ですぜひたくさん
ツイートしてください
もうちょっと盛り上がっていきましょう
山形客さんに怒られたらちょっと高くない
ですか泣きたいけれどちょっとグダっつけ
てそれ野皆さんどうしては絶対ものとかね
でもちょっと人が
してくださることがちょっと止まってき
たら散歩最後試練の言葉を言って生放送も
あろうかと思っております
[音楽]
マサキっなるほどねそれはて何
てかもうすぐクリスマスイブじゃん
あと
[音楽]
4時間ぐらい
4時間だよね
そうだね日付変わるから
[音楽]
クリスマスか
大地くんは嫁ちゃんとスムーズさめちゃ
過ごすけど何も準備していますえっ
ここで言っていいのかわからんができませ
ん
クリスマスプレゼント難しいの
[音楽]
付くと遊ぶ今塾帰りの人とか見てるんだ次
の人は帰りなさい
始め冊を無事チャンネル登録者数
1000万に行きましたーーー
[音楽]
いきますのみなさんありがとうございます
母去っている
が全部ん
まず
2月2末になっているのはぞっ中息子の
記念日に誰飛べませんはっはっは
エコ拒否着拒されてる俺かあちゃんにーず
でしょ
[音楽]
ちょっと待っておかあさーん
2が2だ
[音楽]
ん若木山田孝之さんがいらっしゃってイラ
さんが電話だったんですけど
お強いをこの先はい
ちょっとならだなというふうにはなんです
けど
ちょっとっ
どうせもマックっていただきたいっていう
のが実はあって皆さん末くださいそれも
強い誰が来てくださるのかわかんなくて
コメント読めねぇ
打つか何か良いコメントあったらせて
ください
[音楽]
あのテーマだ
3着供されてるんですけどねキンっ
えっ
お母さんもね僕もそうだけどすごいお世話
になってるからねー本当に
なんか
回転批判コメントで運営されていることは
全部俺のカーチャングリ売ってくれるん
ですよね by も前もっているか動画で
た瞬間と思う
それで
いろいろ
したり鹿の子なって思うことが多くて
何だろう
[音楽]
ありがたいですなーやっぱそのどっ
何歳になっても
チューしてくれるー
なかなか近くにいてくれるのがすごい
ありがたいん
皆様人が近くにいてくれるだけでも
なんか
またまでいられるかというか自分が狂わず
見られるなって思いますから皆
学校とかで怒られたりさん職場で怒られ
たりすると思いますけど
怒られるって言うことまだ
[音楽]
よくできるって思われてるってことだから
皆さんをとってくれる周りの日かを大切に
してあげてください
んですね
ちょっと
実はあのに今お正月っぽくなってるんです
けど
[音楽]
なんかクリスマス用の衣装を準備しており
ますです6パーセントでカンスト
アヌ差別 b そうな
ちょっと違いて頃から
[音楽]
踏み込んありがとうございます本当に
数畑さんスポーツありがとうございます
[音楽]
ん
2お母さんやホントにマジで起こる一第二
ます大事にした方がいいよ
[音楽]
それもなんか
相手の顔がわからない人に怒られてもあ
るって聞かないんですよ
知らないとに誹謗中傷されても絶対に見
ないようにしてるんですけど
顔がわかってちゃんと怒ってくれる人の
意見はすごいちゃんと聞こうと思っていう
自分の中で打っ住んでるよねー
それが俺はかーちゃんだから
なんか28にもなって未だに
怒られるんですよ
すごいありがたいいたしません
[音楽]
ねほんと母いたいって書いてよねなんだい
んだよ
俺も今日母ちゃんに連絡しを邪推な安全
って
待って
馬崎0
えっ今どこに住ん今だ花の中の花きた今日
来ましたおめでとうございありがとう
ございますあの木本当におめでた
不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
不不不不気ができていいねなんで俺は釣れ
ず飲む日でしょとれ被害でくるからまた
ちょっと薄めでそれやばいでしょ聞い
ながらちょっと撮ってないでてますやばい
やばいなで大地くんきってありますよね
あっ派手な困り1年主役がいなくなるん
ですよねバイト続けるよもうもたない
でしょ得づらいだろと思ったら
うワインはうわーホッ
声をあげるからん
声が出るのに
山崎さあ
しゃぶり駅よ
いいです
まあ
ねっ
いやーなんかゴーッと日はっかしいでなん
でプリっても多分に現地からすごいやって
ないから
言われるらしい
俺はもう大地くん書体名を覚えてるから
ねぇ
だからいつもいいよねさどんな書体です
課税さん家のガレージのシャッターを俺が
中からあ気に入って履いた瞬間
で付きで端から端までどうぞフレーゼ
自分一発で御料所タイムで弾こうとしたよ
まあねあのねそういうねあれで本気じゃ
ないわよねそれ面白いんですよ
いやもうそうか本当に年ぶりだよねそうだ
から何か良い
元気原型
店の郊外がってんだギャラリーなあー
始めも2年ぶりグルあってないやろれそう
だよねー
西挿絵
めだか大地くん戻ってきたらめっちゃ売る
人は本当に動画見ながら
[音楽]
あー
が増えてくれーだね
まずねお母さんに頼まないかなあー
いやー
でもやっぱり謎ん
動画投稿年前ぐらいうんにブラストはじめ
と
将生と
でこれなんかカメラ回してるねやってた
じゃん
やっぱりそれで一気に立ってもいません
本当に3人で結構やったよねやったね
色んなことを夜中にクマ探しに行ったんだ
んっ
4日にください傾いねー
山道をねヌーサだしまーすでしまって
一晩中やったねこれ
気づいたらもう朝日がのソーセージだした
のですか
ヤバイことしかやってね
元気元気元気元気元気弁慶せよ
[音楽]
いやもうほんとにめっちゃ嬉しい第二君に
も一さん連中ベチャ嬉しい学びスター
パワーストレートに言ってくれ
これはちょっとひどいでね
今まで上を通ったらん
成長期
映像
ん
俺も太ったんだよね幸せ太りまあまあそう
いうことで人こそたそうだよねおめでとう
ありがとうござい
ございます指輪が光っていますのですね
入ります
あっ
すごいね本当に
中野からながら今日は今日仕事して終わる
と同時にもすぐで聞いて進化させません
やって来ません
またあれではねぜひ今幌
のまでずっとあっち論で800系が入っ
いっても撮影してた場所だったけど今
3億円の豪邸にそうねまだ入ったことで
まだ来ておきないもんね
そうめっちゃキター
億円の強敵になる
何やるかね正木きた瞬間に
地下500m
いやでももう逆にドッキリかけられたよね
あの得られてのすぎてを
さん5年くらいにやられてないからこそが
3000くらいでそう
そろそろ何かドッキリがない日常に慣れて
しまうドッキリを相続しるよ
[音楽]
増えてございますよ
と思ったりします
だもんね
そうですね
でっ
あかあちゃんから電話占いあれだけだ
今雅紀が来ているからごめん変わったんだ
からなんなんだよなぁーまたキャリアと来
てくれて本当にいい
ねえたですねおめでたいし1000万に
行くと思ってたぞやってかもう始めた時さ
そこを全然何も考えずにさそうだねやって
たじゃんだから何か改めてすげーことして
たんだなっていうのが
そうだねすごいかどうかは運次第が世界だ
からね
マサキは本当に
大学生のおふざけでやっていた時からずつ
で平日に最初からあってよねー
そして戦慄のオネエとがを離れません
フェチドッキリ対象としてそうね右下何回
かけられたのだ
なきゃなんとそういう名の
積み重ねというか
masaki
no kage で旋盤惚れたっていう
功績はかなり大きいかなとレバを待って
ます32
緊張元気ですか研究です
来週も祭神て先制ん真面目に学校の先生と
か忘れちゃんっていうのは真面目にやって
ますそうなんだ
人気でしょうねぇ
にそんなことないとそう
この日一番やでも多分ね今の中学生
あんまり知らないと
あそっかそっかロー去年は高校にいて
で去年高校生の生徒とかがなんか小学校の
時から見てますけどああああだから
[音楽]
がもんだけど世代そうそうそうそう備わっ
ているなんですよだからた中学生とか俺が
やってた頃はあんまり見てないと思う
じゃああんまり正木だって言われないに3
寸前まあそうなんだ
言わせられ言われたいね
ああ
[笑い]
授業やりただ狂っございます
音が良かったが先が来てくれる
[音楽]
そんなんにいく過程でかなり重役というか
大きなカギになっていると思う
本当にありがとうございます
[音楽]
んね花に孤独切ったんまーすめっちゃ久々
尿からね俺もこっちでね
突然ごめんねの配信で
ほんといいねこのなんか安心感があるんだ
な長いからねそうだよね
閲覧いいんじゃないですか女子に住め一音
を喫してきます
パパ
いろいろなああ
熟女するでしょ美しいそれは方から
待ち受けにしてを急いでしちゃうしちゃう
うっっ
いやー懐かしいなぁ将生と動画を撮って
日々もん
えっと思う
元祖だもんねガードっていうかもう本当に
ここの掛け合いがなんかそう肇社長の
チャンネルの始まりズバリかてああ
3億円の豪邸に至るまでの全部の家知っ
てるあそっかそっかそうだよソウザ
最初のところから全部しそうだんだよね
登呂遺跡も近くそうそうねパパに明日から
始まるよだそうあっはぁ
そっかそうだねそう
結構古い過去をする
一人かもね動画をに出てて草
うーむも入る前だったですね
そっかそうか冊があるから隅部に入るとき
も最初聞かされてブームもしれないからあ
そっか
ええええん
難しいなぁ
な考えでもう1000万人よく今日行った
ということで
しかもすごいよねどんどんどんどん増えて
そう今超ネット寝てくださる方がいる添え
てですごいですね
てくれず本当に
[音楽]
山田孝之さん沼崎強かったしよかっいませ
んね電話することあるんですよね
一周
そうあの電話してたはの日もん
すごいよ
南部すごい
[音楽]
いう実感あるのなんかですよ
そうこのし茎てからちょっと何とか一択だ
かなこんな感じか
1000万じゃないと切れないですね
普通だしたきれないからめっちゃ光ってる
のねラビはすごいー
また動画でて山崎でも学校で時られちゃう
か
信濃
でもほんと3億円の豪邸も遊びになぁそれ
ぜひ静岡にも行きたいからもうすぐってか
そろそろ
人は住めそうだもんねうんすごいねえませ
ん
いやもうすごい c 部屋もすごいしね
都市マーク
あのー
なんてガスがとってないから beacon
をつかめるという
別なんでアース党とガスが待ってすごいて
見える穴けど
9度な差別なん雪歩っアップ入ったけど
ロサ立ち合いが全然できゅっきゅっきゅっ
ニャーしばらくこりゃ臨機ストーブ
コンセント付高 a 4さぁさぁ園の家で
みずぼらしいですよ
外観はすることが欠かせんだからもう一つ
ですね
遊び子
いうことを考えると変わってないなぁ
やってることを
良い子大きくなっただけでいる
そうだねコツと言うけど中身はね中身は
変わってるぞ
良くも悪くもぬ想い
明日も仕事なんん
それぞれのみなさま雅子休みでだした
パンにされるんですがクリスマスイブと
いうことでクリスマスイブ何もやってない
ですねああ
ほんとデータので混在その後よりその後
です本当いつ何をね
[笑い]
ブーバーし
ていい感じですかねぇ
メイド雅紀が本当におめでとうございます
本当に感謝しておりますも
頭には35件のうち遊びに来てください
本当にそれに今日は後で言って本当にはい
ぜひ
[音楽]
ありゃどうぞ
おっ
[音楽]
ね
今崎が強烈たまってきます変わっていく
だろう
だからこのは彼はそんな悲しくない
そうですね以蔵雅紀でしたありがとう
ございましたーーー
[音楽]
しかし
ここで1回
カーデではせます
そうだね
はさに電話はこのん
今連絡が
食べ処
クルー
すごい本当にいろんな人がありがとう
ございますねもう
[音楽]
一君ここで入っ
ある方から電話がくるすある方から電話が
来
爆発はごめん後に出ますよね
あつっかこれかーちゃんの可能性
アーちゃんではなくはずだない
お母さんは
またあとであとでは改装でねっ
電話誰だろう
[音楽]
抜きます
やそのあなたメガネって電話って思うと
[音楽]
もしもし
おぬしハッピー欲しければいい
ローラねぇ0
超えていうかを上げてかーわーりがとう
ございます roland
お前等別途ありがとう
マジすごい選ん香りかさー
そっきー1000万円のやつやってん
でしょ数1000万人記念がまだ偉人今
だよね売れエアロ
俺何やってるところ今の偽のローラの
を経てあの僕見て僕みたいな庶民ワード
100万にトップ機でやってますよ動く
100万人ロアン100万人きれねぇ
速乾型声は解説とあの動画もあるところで
よくなっちゃうそうだねまぁたっ時々確か
違うねぇからさ
間違いないですね1犠打4月4年
ぞっちちゃ目標だ後
目標まであの79億9900万って言っ
たら俺ならず9億9903人苦労などが
なくてもなるほど
目標まですだからまあまあちょっと
はじめの一歩って感じから100万って
言うのねローランドはここからだから
そうだよねこっからだよねっ2分ん
100ms 美酒
1しかちょっとしくったよねーか
定期船か現実にありがとう
くりさせたりする
くれますねちょっと動画取ろうと思ってる
ように
おーわー
ロランドあったりするのも
オレはー
俺はねぇ
やっぱさー
俺色んな女と待っているんだけどん
えっいろんな記録浅い2広く浅く広く浅い
女走るんだけどやっぱクリスマス区と別
じゃあそうだね
お宝だったそこはきっとこうしたら
小中感じられるそうで確かに何か私のの
こと好きなのってなっちゃうかもしれない
からそうそう俺ね俺で1個びろ聞いて始め
あれ世の中にはれ1個ぐらい誰も登れてや
貼ってもいいと思うんだよね大
あるだがれますが折れそういう存在でい
たいわけよ
ローラーとは誰かほらにもたらでみたいな
んまるほどなるほど
まあ要するにたがり病構えクリパたひとり
でした
オズマさん
ローラーの味でしたあおいおいおいおい家
やったなぁ
確かには100万円と千万も
0違うだけだからローランドからすると
小さな違いかもしれないです
いうことが真の人も
今年から外れてあったんだけど本当に
すごいしていっ
ないでしょ同じじゃないも少ないですよ
始めたときちょっと凄すぎてさ
稽古使ってたんだけど前橋ということに
続いてそれからもためまで話になって
大地くんとでください塗装
あのローランドかな
半ばでなんか嬉しいなぁすごいよねー
すごいちょっと六突然来てごめんと言って
おくとかはっはっ
乗ってくれた
[音楽]
めちゃめちゃローランドさんの
海のすごいよなんか面白かっこいい
すごいよな
プチブラの方本当に
に強くに目指しますか
01個強いだけですからね
皆さん是非チャンネル登録よろしくお願い
しますまだの方も是非
ただそんな某そろそろかな
もつい
いろんな人にお会いして
覚えてきたんですけど
いうの本当におめでとうございます
コメントが止まらなくて本当にうれしい
[音楽]
her and her なんかになり
たいと思った時もあったえっ
[音楽]
金さんいる精勤さんいる右側
2時なす罰はマジしか千金さん
[音楽]
きてますよ
金さんは坊
みてくださ区
数人さんから
一君2000万人突破はベイダー
ぜひずありがとうございます
あーにがとうございますえっ
[音楽]
ポッちゃーん
えっ
なと思います
[音楽]
エンジン3ちょっと一句に
祝福ずつ影使ってい
[音楽]
びっくりです去年だったかな
去年時ですねやったねえっ売ってたねー
やってた奴買ったが
兄さんみたいなその後結果されて
youtube を両立されているって
いうのはすごい
ちょっと裏います
憧れると言うねぇ
野中いいいい
パパーンうーん a
そんな感じがしますおりません
えっとそれじゃあのかあさんから電話かけ
てくるなと言われますね
ng らしいですけどね
そそこが年はやっぱりがたいよねそうだ
ねー
ほんと何か
いい意味で色々ダメって言ってくれるはさ
なんですよ
1000万人っても電話ダメです
ありがたい本当に良い
マザコンというわけでもないもんねそうだ
ね
なーって感じたいた空
逆になんだろ
始め9より俺の方がタブお母さんに結構
連絡とか電話してるし私が確か確かにまあ
業務的な言葉をの話のもそうだね
昨日怒られる時だけでなくくるっていう力
で直接
そうなんですよ
本当にありがたいことに
なんかかあさんのことまず今じゃないん
ですけど人として本当に尊敬してますので
今
[音楽]
かあちゃんだけなくて家族をねぇー
登録者がなくまた現キャンと増えてきて
おります
27,000
こいね
[音楽]
まず今じゃないの血が付いてなかったこと
は今彷徨っえっ俺はマザコンだったら多分
今も実家の富山の印綬トーン
[音楽]
ぞ
大学で静岡に一人暮らしできて
広がった世界だから youtube
[音楽]
そのためマザコンだったロライマ画廊落ち
てパパや詰めていっです
スキャンドローバーみってやってたかも
しれないん
てマザボんじゃないですよっ
好きですけど
[音楽]
生きてるん
沢山釣っと読めるだけ車せていただきます
すみませんちょっと全部拾えずに
[音楽]
yuta さんの胸が思う
さっき来てた3万円くれた監督さんて方が
ね俺サベナ言ってたらたまたまこの人にお
会いして
監督を知っててよくコメントくるから
サウナで出場者さん出会うっていう
[音楽]
でもありがとうございます
5弾がとうございます
例えばから250円はきついですよ
そうよ見ていくっ
はスマートさんありがとうございます
むっちゃってコメントしてるんちゃ
実は俺の市バスチャンネルの一つに進め
ちゃっ
[音楽]
妙のみんな本当に
サムライってみたいまで行ったことないん
だサウナ
マジ
大キラン
大地くんさんがに復旧
好きで右たいんだけど
嫁さんがんまサーバーます気じゃないなだ
からガッツイ奴嫌だったろうほんとやぞ
ためにあたるものの根本
確かチョップ好き嫌いは彼はするよねー
気持ちな位置に結構メディエイトまた
part 3250ありがとうございます
ありがとうございます結婚祝ですね
ねってことないです
[音楽]
ん
きっこ入っている珍しいで俺がこんなに
長い時間の場合センスよ
[音楽]
なかなかないと思いますねこれからも
1000万人記念じゃないと多分購入生
配信よりしないと思うから
ひょっとしたら最初で最後はもしれない
2000万人
行く時はやろっかな座
2000万に行くと決まっ
[音楽]
最近は良い子が走りですーっ
本当ありがとうございます
コメントしっかり見てます
なぜ6月1もにお
[音楽]
をお願いします来年の終わりますか
来年の抱負は
[音楽]
そうだなんだろう
ああああああ
山の1000万人のことしか考えてなかっ
た画風の1000万人
そうそう圧のそう
来年の事全然考えても何にも今年で突いて
終わるぐらいだと思ってるなら
ちょっと来年の抱負せめて今
ないです実は a
今後の目標とかもちょっと
きてこない
のでー
ちょっと一家いう落ち着いて
自分と話してみます
も楽しみなやばいやばいよついてあります
けど
ちょっと突っ走っちゃった目るー
落ち着いて
考えてみます
だからやりたいことはまだたくさんあるん
のでみなさんぜひついてきてくれると
嬉しいです
はいお願います始め
ファザコンを
父ちゃんはね
スキーだけどそんなキャッパーみたいな
感じだなん
父ちゃんも結構厳しい人というか
[音楽]
そう
ね割としっかり
自分で言うのもおかしいけどしっかり育て
られた方だと思う
初パスを送っちゃおう横におめでとう
ございますもありがとうございます
といえばから応援していますありがとう
ございます
デブなんとっ
[音楽]
本当にありがとうございます
すごいのヒカキンさんが来られてから結構
時間経ってる
めっちゃいろんな方が来てくださってませ
んと思う
[音楽]
始めパパの華ちゃんあまり出ないそうだね
父ちゃんはねぇ
なんか湯という立地背中で語ってくれる
タイプ突破
多くを語らないタイプ
って俺は思ってるまたいいんだけど10年
[音楽]
注ぐ格好いい父ちゃんだから何かあ
何か良いとかという本当に
線形できる登山でません
毎月の父様
んぢゃんぢゃ
粗糖ちゃう
なんかもう
声がもう
が悪いん
[音楽]
ん
いやいや聞いて
いいぞそうなんか6水が当然ぞってむずい
よねー
家になる桃ちゃんかっこいいけどそういう
親しみのある東山
皆さんのお父さんはどういう落とす
でしょうか
本堂が楽しいと思ってますありがとう
ございます
スポーツしたら読んでもらいます2可能
スポーツは=読む見てるわけじゃないです
よ
[音楽]
ありがたいなあ本当にたくさんのコメント
するわけでちょっと宝札うお願いです
まだあるらしいので
それもばたみたい
弟さんに電話して
元中国んできる
そうね潤香クールだと思う
[音楽]
変わったを打つ言われてるなオレ
響さんありがとうございます猪木さーん
松ありがとうございます
未だにあるか俺おりませんだ俺もするんだ
よねこれも待ってるだけだからいいもん俺
もわからないんでまずときっ
またはてもうやばいの誕生日よりお祝い
ライン比べる
あああっっ鍛造よりお湯を選んくるよ今日
[音楽]
本当にも歴史的な瞬間だったん
さっきまでめっちゃないんだけどいろんな
人といっ
いろんな人が多い林てくれたら嬉しくなっ
てきちゃうん
[音楽]
ありがたいよ本当に
でしたああ
青でたです
すごい
うんゆきみのさねええええ
いいしなかっただー30度うんいいね
でしょ
いやーすごいいやその前におめで悪れたら
女ありがとうございまーす
いいですねぇ
同代理と思う
衣装もなんか気が得られ上がるとかして
saas 牧師となった
[音楽]
姉さんはー
結構唯一させ a 9 e
はいっ
矢板武樹記念さが一番長くて綺麗だと思う
水でしたあ全然連絡とってろってレベルの
ねえねえ本年に1回言う奴おめっそれでも
トップレベル関係してるッ
9分ヘッジ暑くないですかねで恋しい
ちゃうすっごいか若くなっててなんで
だろうと思うんですけどめっちゃ暑い暑い
ですけどあ確かにそうかもと思ってるから
かな
あっありがとうございますやっぱりもあの
もう持ってらっしゃった挽くためなんです
けどいい
ございません
やめでとうございませんありがとうござい
ます
ここが2そうなんですよ
今日も思ってるんですね気球で買ってきた
んです磨崖卵ですでございなたいなんてね
失礼しますはい
[音楽]
あっあぁああああ
でわっ
いいかなと画面2はれます
あの
純情せよたジャズよだよせよ
ねえねえかああそれねもうアニバーサリー
コレクションだそれですよホントなんか
モンスターボールのキラキラみたいな奴が
いやの中のポケセン
にょ渡そうと思ったんですけどねーよなぁ
7万7000もそれから染められちゃあー
止めないでください
マネージャーさあ
誰これ3つも買うと言わないと思う
ありがとうございます食べちゃったの一番
新しいやつやろブリッジまぁそうですよね
いや全然これも見るとかめちゃくちゃ強い
あっこ姉がすでーずっとフェアのえっ
ちゃんにお勧めを聞いて
入っちゃっポケモン噛んじゃってそうなん
ですよ
それはですねプリピアノ
ねーっ
理由の訪問おまけ論文
はぁ
ませ
う
そりゃ当然のぜひえっドラフト戦でもやっ
て遊んでくださいね
上的すぎてうれしいえーっあっ
ますなんかもう結構いろんな人がいろんな
ものを渡してたからねーよ私たら喜ぶん
だろう痛いな
もう難しい難しいですねぇ
まあこのスレ13ていない中でも栄養を
こちらこそ本当にみんなにはねすごいの
驚かせる誰だってですけどそれじゃねぇ
もう失恋の傷は癒えたんですか続突っ込ん
できます母と子の引きはいビッグイベント
にタイマーびっくり命さえシエラ取材に
そうですね
じゃあなんかあのもういいたつもりでは
いるんですけどあの国は時々地雷んんんん
んんん a
にとってもなんかはいが1年するためサル
はそうですねー
なんか緊張してますねファーってほんとに
すごいですねー
でもう何前にも見てるじゃないですかそう
でそこを突破したんでちょっと落ち着いて
きているんですけどかかったよね
皆さんというかにゃんずに皆さんがすごい
に守りな可能本当にいやなんかちょっと私
もずっと見てたねー感極まっちゃいました
ねーよハゲ酒ちょっと候補ロリーとした
ところで運ん僕だけもないだろそれ
ございません
宇津野ちゃんとりくべつ物理出さないって
さっきは結構嫌ですよね
いろんな方が来てくださったねはいえーと
今何かうれしさっかあ勝ってる
阿部さんの小走り者舞台に女の子離せない
みたいな話をしてたと思うんですけどなん
か無茶だけど結構忘れられないエピソード
があって雑魚なんです
なつきお母さんカーテンいう中バッター
だったらどっきりっていうのをよ
チャンネルでやったんですよねモーニング
ユーチューバーさんみんな読んででぜひ
あのあのえっちゃんとカード+ちゃんとか
女の子で手に取りが一さんなぜ一人みたい
そうなんですよね感じだったんですよって
その時にあの
一人ずつ発表会さんに入ってで手間店員な
んでお掃除したりとかコーナーガレージ
打ったりとかで私が0タントだからで
レイジーを落とし
人生であんまり kk した方なくてもか
言ってますよねそうなんですよねなんか
すごい子はと私ててやばいやばいみたいな
んでも後2人に入ったらこれでもあのネタ
ばらしたからとってが一生驚異こうやって
体で細部1人源さんが来るぞみたいな段階
で
てみたいな中古車身近な感じになって石
なく5分ぐらい本立ってもこれ見たいぞ
欲しい
マイカーみたいだなんて行かなかったんだ
けど a
それで10分くらいたって
でまぁみたいな感じ登場されたんですよで
まぁ別に全然それはそれで面白い感じ取り
からねああよかったよかったみたいな感じ
だったんですけど最後は d さんに何か
じゃあ従属くるの遅くなかったですか
みたいな言ったら一さんが
入れに行きたかったら救えねえなんか全員
女性クリエイターデー誰に対してもその
トイレに行きたいという命令を大事も作ら
れてあって
ああああああぶー
ぶーっ
今迷ったらコレ中で話したいと思って
もらったわけですね話しかけにあのへ
みんなで頑張ります
だけど女性との会話が苦手なもんねー
ブーバーそりゃティムロス
その運かねお話したかったですね
んだけど無理なんだろうなぁも性格的に
ないんだと思いますじゃあ部だってくれ
だけな訳輸注バーをやっててねー
話せないはもう無理だと思いますよ
長いですよねっ
ですよね結構クラブをさせてもらってから
折れた時間たっても私のいわしもだいぶ
変わってるはずなんですけど未だに結構割
と話せても本音ですかありがとうござい
ます忘れちゃきた時固まってるんで思う
くださいねーやれずっとないか愛が決定は
してうんめえええええたの中ではトップ
クラスに話せる女性でくるよかったですよ
です今後ともぜひ宜しくお願いします
いこーへー
[音楽]
ちょっと構え六話になるんですけど私が
こう
ブームに入った理由の一つが正源さんなん
ですよねそうだよね正しいです
ヒカキンさん今一番憧れっていうのはあっ
たんですけどやっぱはじめさんっていう
まあ大きな口ゲーターさんがい
るっていうのがスゴイ自分の中で目指すて
表みたいなところで
なんでなんかそんな方にこんな一番版なん
か女性の中で話しやすいて言っていただけ
てすごくうれしい
しかもねこんな大事な音1000万人って
言う突破のところにムーン中に選んで
いただいたの本当に
sa 飲んでも大丈夫
[音楽]
ですねずっと肌入ってるんですけどおいて
軽いじゃあ楽にちょっとかせていた
誰かじっなんか実感としては
いやぁなんか
さっきガッと来て入らないそうですよね
ちょっとヒカキンさんにお湯をイシャルっ
てやそうですよね1分
ってなるとゆっくりよ
明太いろいろ解けちゃっていうわーーー
みんな nai
はい
けど本当にいろんなクレーターさあが今お
祝いしに来てくださいん
あっちって結構楽しい思い出回目が入った
ああ
やっぱり
協力してはい
仲間だという感じでほどん
切磋琢磨してねあ作りして来てるって言っ
たので中野1000万人行ったらやめるか
もみたいな道があったじゃないですか流れ
を見てえそんな感じだったがを通ったつつ
すごいびっくりしちゃって歩こう仮定した
んですよ
けど一生者の皆さんねちょっと気づい
てらっしゃる方もいたんだよそうです良い
ですよねぇ
遠藤とかはいでもわかるのかなというふう
きましたんですけどすごいですよね
follow 私の中でやっぱアジアへ
さんと仕掛け子さんにはういっしょ
youtube がある限り
ユーチューバー続けたは生です
ユーチューバーやってる限り結婚的に気が
してるんだーっ
は確かにそうだおっあるかもしれないです
ね全てを投げ出しちゃうキーですね
まあ4匹結果自体ちょっとない加工そう
いけるじゃないそれがヒカキンさんも結構
するか
そういう感じですレアル買いが入って入っ
て
思うんですよ今後の年間目標も全然さっき
聞かれてもまだわかんなことを実践何か
するって聞いたんでそうですよね今真っ白
なんでうーん年内ははいえー
動画
また全然予定なんて運
岩盤で来年またちょっとあなたの目標を
つくって頑張りでも
感じですじゃあ s ね新年の抱負
ちょっと楽しみにしてますねえふぇ食い
ながらでもねはーい1年間コメントしてる
んだろそうですよねいやー結構きつくない
ですか[ __ ]に米内のきつくないですか
これかつに米内の方になんですよとんかつ
なんですね
かつにめっちゃ待ってって
はいでもお米
何も話していない
よあーおれ
解除されたらもうとんかつ食べたいなと
いう大大大
じゃあ10日と食べながらちょっと
目標でも話しつつそうですねんっ
でもまだま日記見せしようかなって考えと
思う
そうですよねー
なく切符んだか自分の中で愛であるんです
か外出禁止者もソロそうだかと思っ
予防することだじゃないかその
その中でああああ寝る
ジャンク
会質疑していけるんじゃないかなと思って
はい
で猛毒です1年後セントはあげるよえっ
これだ
これが外からんですけど
ちょっと仕事に支障出過ぎるだといや
間違いないよそうですよいやだって遊戯王
の大会とかもてれなくなりますから東亜の
オンラインでねはいですがいつか
レディスコートネイリスクールねーなー
さーんっ
ですね息は来年もぜひ宜しくお願いします
ぜひざまぁを蘇生クリエイターさん
お腹いっぱい少ないんそうだよね
事実はですねあの一さんにスペシャル
ゲスト
あの読んでるんですけどちょっとしたこれ
磯スペシャルゲスト
ええいいですかはい
すると思っ
言われています
[音楽]
っていうこうやって待って待って待って
待って待って待って待って待って待って
ます
すいませんちょっとこんなきたねっ
江藤じゃんあありがとうございますござい
ますameあっありがとうございます有村
e サンデー
そう思っていますをお願いします
みましています初めましてですねいいよ
文ねーなく一さんがありぐらい作すごい
好きだっていう話
ていたと思うてたのん
んでてたんで
うざーい持ってくださいね心臓止まりそう
ですすいませんだか番組で勝手にお名前を
出すでしょうでもう栄でしたありがとう
ございました
ご迷惑じゃなかったんですか嬉しいか女か
い
[音楽]
にはめてください
こうなっちゃうんですっっ
すみません本当にネットうんっ
あっほんとですかありがとうございます
てくだ黄金ん
たまに見られています
後ろが壁がレンガ僕で神の滝ああ
本当ですかありがとうございます
ん tan本当にっ
うれしいねもう
これ以
スパッツ手順江坂制度はとしてありまし
たってです
ツイテルさんありがとうございました
まあ本当にガスが入ってません
いいですかもちろんねちょっときゃさせて
いただきます
開けますねー
[音楽]
いていただきます
品ちょちょっと待って a
俺今日で死ぬのかなあー
いただきます
まあ昔がー
月高させていただきます
でも食べるのもったいないなーリベラえり
さんかなーっ
ていますけど
ずっとぽっぷっなく
ありがとうございまーすお貸しいただき
ましたーーー
何を見てくださいねありがとうございます
本当に
夢でこの足場の悪い中を持っていたねっ
ございます
[音楽]
まず大雪上これちょっ
か動画見てくださってるんですね初耳でし
たそれは目
ねすごいびっくりしましたが本当ですね
みっていやいやそこ
またや対馬だよ本当に
なっちゃうんですよね
女性との会話が苦手でんあと人見知りも
ありましてですね
同じなので大丈夫本当ですか
よかった2つしましたそれは間違いでは
ない空気ということで
はて線万円いって
ありむらいさば入ると思ってなかったわー
んっ
[音楽]
すごいね本当に
ありがとうございます
ちょっとまた何か機会がありましたら
4一緒できてないやろしくお願いしちゃい
ます
あの出演されているえむえむぶ最も見て
いるうれしいる
施設内のみですありがとうございます
また来年もよろしくお願い致しますね
もっと今後願いしまーすね
youtube 楽しみにおはようござい
ます頑張ります
[音楽]
ぜひ最後に2000万人
頑張ってくださいって言ってもらっていい
ですはい
2000万人頑張ってくださいありがとう
ございます決まりました次の目標
えっ
本当にありがとうございましたけど
こそそうなっちゃうなん
ちょっと緊張しちゃうんですよすいません
でもないんです
[音楽]
チェーンマンでイってこんなことになるの
か
アップライです綺麗なちょっともいろいろ
[音楽]
今年で楽しいことありましたか
福祉そうですね楽しいこといっぱいでも
いいか本当ですから特に今年
音が一番1がこれといってある皆さん的に
自分のブランドを立ち上げていたあそう
ですよねー
twitter で花弁させて食べており
ますありがとうロシアてください
始め走破
皆様さまなんてを選んでください
僕は
year
でもこの瞬間ですね1000万人があって
い
なかなか到達できないっていうことでー
のでそれが今日達成できて本当に今年の
一番の
まさに締めくくりというかん今年の一番の
思い出になりましたん
素晴らしい素敵な日にお会いできて
嬉しいです
えええっ
やっても使えます
ua 大手レジャー同じ待って本当に
[音楽]
本気でですね
ございません
第一か助けてちょっと o
でも彼本当に
愛理さんのことを好きでずっと言ってるん
ですよそんなさんといいですね
[音楽]
こっちまで緊張してね偽装ん
インチの春草ぞ
[音楽]
問われたと思うね
2000万に行くしか
そうですね
ありがとうございます新しい目標がいい
いやけども数字追いかけるの辛いなぁ
[音楽]
数字の来栖球を味わったからない専門に
いく過程で運営
楽しくそうですね晴れ
なければ
楽しみ楽しみうっていう
持ってみませんしていいのかもしれない
ですね何
[音楽]
もうちょっとはって本当に2庁舎親バレ
えっ
第二こんなに立つのはたい事はないんだ
けど
ないよこんな機械ほんとそうだよねでも
そんなこと言うとも会えなくなって込んだ
と思いますけどなんだからない
他の機械の時に
ぜひ宜しくお願いしますよろしくお願い
致します
[音楽]
でも9時だ
汝が6時からやってるっていう
続時から3時間あったんですかが全然疲れ
を感じてない
[音楽]
いろんな感情が
ココアていっ
なっているのを見ててああ
は的ねほんとですかねあと最初のない
てらっしゃったところずっとルールって私
という国内でもしたっけ
[音楽]
濡れてますねっ
ですねうん性もありがとうございますっ
そうちょっと楽しいことばっかりでも
なかったねー
思い出がうん入ってしまいましたん
うれしいが一番立っていますで今いい
金目ラインサンくるっ
ネイルですお邪魔します
use
すごいなぁん
あ
youtube 見てますよ
またでファイバー
ありがとうに表示されてるのはいいい
目指して食べて
応援です
難しい
[音楽]
ちょっとあなたれぞれシャネルところほん
とっ
緊張でシーンですよねこれ
本当に
[音楽]
今年の最後はクリスマス前でお会いできた
のと思うんですはいん
そうですよねあずらせたが2分ですね
これからもよろしくお願いしますますいい
よすいませんありがとうございますさも
撮影です頑張ってくださりございます
[音楽]
でございますございましたまたよろしくお
願います
選手もおりぶらりーさんでしたーー
あーさー
[音楽]
はありません
やすんですごめんねみんなの
放送絶好みたいになっちゃいましたけど
図5ではないです
ああなってしまいますとかえっ
[音楽]
やばいやばいやばいよ前
んですっ
ありがとうございます本当に
僕のあ
千万
1003舌線3万人いきました
後ほい高層棟23万人増えてしまった
ありがとうございますみなさんチャンネル
登録していただいて
いやー
すっごい長い時間やってたなぁ
[音楽]
というわけで
すごいなんか1年の本当に
なんか今年を
彩る方にお会いできたかなという集大成と
いうかでもとしお世話になった人がも一気
に行こうこの3時間
ありがとうございます本当に
はいクールちょっと
9時になったのでそろそろ
みようかなと思ってます
くれず本当に今日生放送見てくださった皆
さん本当にありがとうございますがござい
ました
本当におかげさまで1000万人
到達することができました
これは
まあ僕のっ
地下なっ
というか
部がも図2月全力でやろうと思って
ほんと動画のことだけを考えて
をしてきたんですけども
1000万に行くかどうかって服どうこう
より
見てくださる方が積める登録しようって
思ってくれるかどうかだと思うので
の1000万人いたのはー
視聴者さんの皆さんファンの皆さん
最近応援してくださった方
もですし昔から応援してくださってる方の
おかげで
頭とすることができました本当に
ありがとうございましたん
動画でも話なんですけどもマジで4回キリ
がいいからやめようって思ったのもずっつ
で
[音楽]
かっこいいじゃないすか今ここであ財政
マンに行ったんだよ見ますつかシャープっ
ターンていくのかっこいいと思ったんです
けど
まだやりたいこととかしたいこととか
[音楽]
この先
1000万人入ったからこそ見える景色も
あると思うんで
[音楽]
始め殺王はここからまた新たにスタート
するかなと
思います
[音楽]
マイナ先もジャン泣きしちゃったん
まぁちょっと
とりあえず年内はもう結構まだ結構仕込ん
でるんですよ朝
1000万に行く様の動画結構から仕込ん
でいてここから多分動画
個人的には面白いと思うがたくさん出ると
思うんですけど
チャンネル登録された方はこれからの
はじめ殺音をどうかよろしくお願い致し
ます
ごめんねちょっと色んな方がいらっしゃっ
たからちょっと結構長い尺の生放送になっ
てしまったんですけれども
沢山のことに祝っていただいて本当に幸せ
な時間でした
はい
というわけ
1000万人
いきましたけども
今年ももう少しにあるけど来年も始め冊を
どうかよろしくお願い致します
以上はじめしゃちょーでしたジャガー
[音楽]
ていた
me
[音楽]
おおおおおおおお
true
ていた
[音楽]